Hi, I'm here. I'm here in the room. Just being as quiet as I can. I'm so excited to be on the country. Specifically, our northern brother or sister? Yeah. We may have talked about this before, but when you go home, do you sleep in this, your old room? Your parents' bed.
嗨，我到了。我已经在房间里了。尽量保持安静。我很高兴能来到这个国家。具体来说，是我们的北方兄弟姐妹吗？对。我们以前可能讨论过这个，但当你回家时，你睡在这间你以前的房间里吗？你父母的床上。
I sleep with my parents. Oh. Because I always, it gave me comfort to get in between them, so I sleep with my parents. Mommy, daddy, cuddles? Yeah. No, I don't stay here. I don't stay here.
我和我父母一起睡。哦。因为我总是，挤在他们中间让我很有安全感，所以我跟我父母一起睡。妈咪、爹地，抱抱？对。不，我不住这儿。我不住这儿。
Settle me. Could you ever live there again? In Toronto? Yeah. Yeah, I'm not, I don't stay here. Settle me. Could you ever, could you ever live there again? In Toronto? Yeah. Yeah, by the way, I could. Will, do you have a second piece of gum you could put in your mouth for the record? Just to get it in stereo?
让我清醒一下。你还能在那里生活吗？在多伦多？对。对，我不是，我不住这儿。让我清醒一下。你还能，你还能在那里生活吗？在多伦多？对。对，顺便说一句，我可以。威尔，你嘴里有第二块口香糖可以放进去吗，为了录音效果？只是为了弄成立体声？
This is actually, too, I know. I just realized. That'd be great. I heard it myself. Let's go ahead and, thank you. So we're recording now, you were saying. Yeah, it's an audio medium. It is an audio, okay, got it.
其实这也是，我知道。我刚意识到。那太好了。我自己听到了。我们开始吧，谢谢。所以我们现在在录音，你刚才在说。对，这是一个音频媒介。它是一个音频，好吧，明白了。
You know, Toronto is very, it's a great city and I is an audio, okay, got it. Toronto is very, it's a great city and I could live here and there's so much stuff I love about it. The problem is it's very gray from November to June. It's Chicago, it's basically Chicago. I think it's grayer, I think you get more gray days. It's just where it sits between the Great Lakes, et cetera. We don't wanna get into Ontario weather patterns, but it is great.
你知道，多伦多非常，这是一个伟大的城市，我是一个音频，好吧，明白了。多伦多非常，这是一个伟大的城市，我可以在这里生活，这里有很多我喜欢的东西。问题是，从11月到6月，这里非常阴暗。这里是芝加哥，基本上就是芝加哥。我觉得这里更阴沉，我觉得这里的阴天更多。这只是因为它位于五大湖等等之间。我们不想深入探讨安大略省的天气模式，但它真的很棒。
Otherwise, it's awesome. So you think that that would make you somewhat blue, kind of like what people talk about in England and stuff like that? I don't know. Yeah, I think I feel like I like it. Yeah, I do too. I think it's cozy.
除此之外，它棒极了。所以你认为这会让你有点沮丧，有点像人们在英国谈论的那种情况？我不知道。对，我想我觉得我挺喜欢的。对，我也是。我觉得这很温馨。
It's so cozy, right? But you know, England, it rains and stuff, but you do get sunny days. Toronto, it's not even that it gets a lot of rain, it's that it gets a lot of cloud cover specifically. And I think at a certain point you just see. You know, it's reminding me once I had this dream. You do have the maple leaves there though,
非常温馨，对吧？但你知道，英国会下雨什么的，但你确实能看到晴天。多伦多甚至不是因为经常下雨，而是因为经常多云。我觉得到了某个时候，你就会看到。你知道，这让我想起我曾有过的一个梦。不过你那里有枫叶，
so doesn't that offset it a bit? I do have the maple leaves here. I'm really excited about that. You're in town for some hockey, right? Yeah, this is gonna come out way after, but I'm in town for the All-Star game. I had a great night, dinner last night, with some of the boys from a hockey podcast
所以这难道不能稍微抵消一下吗？我这儿确实有枫叶。我对此非常兴奋。你这次来是为了看冰球比赛，对吧？对，这期节目播出时已经过去很久了，但我这次来是为了全明星赛。我昨晚度过了一个美好的夜晚，和一档名为
called Spit and Chicklets. Oh, is that right, eh? Oh yeah, with Biz and Ryan Whitney and the boys. Oh, right on. Yeah, yeah. Spit and Chicklets. And it was so super fun, interesting dudes, really, really funny, we had a lot of big laughs.
《Spit and Chicklets》的冰球播客的一些男孩们一起吃了晚饭。哦，是吗？哦，对，跟比兹（Biz）还有瑞安·惠特尼（Ryan Whitney）他们这帮人。哦，原来如此。对，对。《Spit and Chicklets》。这真的超级有趣，都是些很有意思的家伙，非常非常搞笑，我们开怀大笑了好多次。
That's fine. Well, that's gonna be fun for you, taking part in that All-Star weekend, right? Aren't you managing a team with Conor McDavid? I am, I'm like the celebrity co-captain. Yeah. Guys, I can't wait to talk to our guest today. Can't wait for you to talk to our guest today.
那挺好的。那对你来说挺有意思的，能参与那个全明星周末，对吧？你不是在和康纳·麦克David一起管理一支球队吗？我是，我有点像是名人联合队长。对。伙计们，我等不及要和我们今天的嘉宾聊聊了。等不及要你和我们今天的嘉宾聊聊了。
He's considered one of the finest actors of his generation. Wait to shoehorn that in, Sean. I can't fucking. Listener, he's holding up a shoehorn. Okay, don't worry. My dad's got two on his desk. Smell them.
他被认为是她那一代最优秀的演员之一。等一下，你可真会生搬硬套，肖恩。我他妈的。听众朋友们，他正举着一个鞋拔子。好吧，别担心。我爸的桌上有两个。闻闻它们。
By the way. Sorry, I'm sorry, I couldn't. Why do you have those? Can't you just use your finger? How many times have we said that? Ask my dad, I'll get my dad in here. He's got two. All right, sorry.
顺便说一句。对不起，对不起，我不能。你为什么会有这些？你难道不能就用你的手指吗？我们说过多少次了？问我爸，我把我爸叫来。他有两个。好吧，对不起。
Sorry, guest. We go. Listen, I'm not trying to highlight whatever his stuff is on his desk guys What I'm like, he's so giddy that he's at home he turns small. I know feels comfortable. That's still holding his teddy bear I do anyway here we go. Let's not keep him. Let's not keep him waiting any longer He's he's very busy and he's a huge major global star. And he's much younger than us.
对不起，嘉宾。我们开始吧。听着，我不是想强调他桌子上的那些乱七八糟的东西，伙计们。我只是觉得，他回到家里高兴得像个孩子，整个人都变随和了。我知道，觉得很自在。那家伙还在抱着他的熊娃娃呢。不管怎样，我们开始吧。我们别让他等了。我们别让他等太久了。他非常忙，是个超级大牌的全球巨星。而且他比我们年轻得多。
He's not just a Hollywood royal, but he legitimately comes from, and I did not know this, real Swedish nobility, it's true. Oh, well, well. A man of many talents, he's fluent in French like Will. He's musically inclined like me and loves to cook not like Jason. He even made an appearance once making pasta with Mario Batali on Food Network's Molta
他不仅是好莱坞的皇室成员，而且我才知道，他名正言顺地来自真正的瑞典贵族，这是真的。哦，好吧，好吧。多才多艺的人，他像威尔一样精通法语。他像我一样有音乐天赋，而且喜欢做饭，不像杰森。他甚至还在美食频道的《莫尔塔》节目中
Mario. It's my favorite just on screen homosexual, the brilliant Jake Gyllenhaal. Jake Gyllenhaal! Bravo! Hello Jake. Oh, it's been a long time. Jakeula Gyllenhaal. There he is.
马里奥》里客串过做意大利面。我最喜欢的银幕同性恋者，才华横溢的杰克·吉伦哈尔。杰克·吉伦哈尔！太棒了！你好，杰克。哦，好久不见。杰克ula·吉伦哈尔。他来了。
Oh, you have the whole name. I don't know if... Is it really? Is Jakeula the long version of Jakeula? Jakeula Gyllenhaal. Jakeula Gyllenhaal. Jakeula Gyllenhaal. Jakeula Gyllenhaal. Jakeula Gyllenhaal. Jakeula Gyllenhaal. Jakeula Gyllenhaal. There he is. Oh, you have the whole name.
哦，你连全名都叫出来了。我不知道这……真的是吗？杰克ula是杰克ula的长版名字吗？杰克ula·吉伦哈尔。杰克ula·吉伦哈尔。杰克ula·吉伦哈尔。杰克ula·吉伦哈尔。杰克ula·吉伦哈尔。杰克ula·吉伦哈尔。杰克ula·吉伦哈尔。他来了。哦，你连全名都叫出来了。
I don't know if... Is it really? Is Jakeula the long version? It's Jakeula, yeah. No. Count Jakeula? You know, Jake, you've probably heard this before, but I have so much trouble spelling your name that in the Google search, I just put GY and it comes up.
我不知道这……真的是吗？杰克ula是长版名字吗？是杰克ula，对。不对。雅各布伯爵？你知道，杰克，你可能以前听过这个，但我拼你的名字实在太费劲了，所以在谷歌搜索里，我只要输入GY它就出来了。
Yeah, they're like, we got it. It's easy like that. Well, Jake, wait, are you still... Do got it. Yeah. It's easy like that. Well, Jake, wait, are you still, do we still live near each other? Where are you at? We don't, I mean, I moved to New York. Ah, you lucky man.
对，他们就像是，我们懂了。就是这么简单。好吧，杰克，等等，你还在……懂了。对。就是这么简单。好吧，杰克，等等，你还在，我们还住在附近吗？你在哪儿？我们不在，我的意思是，我搬到纽约去了。啊，你这个幸运儿。
Oh. You lucky man. Didn't we go up, what was the name of that dog, Runyon? Yeah, we. Jake is a world-class bicyclist. Are you really? Which should come as no surprise to anyone who's seen his silhouette.
哦。你这个幸运儿。我们以前不是去过，那只狗叫什么名字，鲁尼恩？对，我们。杰克是个世界级的自行车手。真的吗？任何看过他剪影的人都不会感到惊讶。
Yeah, have you guys known each other because you both grew up here? No, how did we get to know one another? I mean, we did live near one another. We had some mutual friends. We hung out for a bit. We did some bike riding for a bit. And then I gassed.
对，你们俩是因为都在这里长大才认识的吗？不是，我们是怎么认识的？我的意思是，我们确实住在附近。我们有一些共同的朋友。我们一起厮混了一阵子。我们一起骑了一会儿自行车。然后我没劲了。
Jake kept going. And I think Mike might. You're one of the best descenders that I've ever seen. I could get into a tuck. That is the world's greatest back-handed compliment I've ever heard. Nobody goes down a hill like you.
杰克继续往前骑。我想迈克可能。你是我见过的最厉害的下坡高手之一。我可以缩成一团。这是我听过的世界上最伟大的反讽赞美。没有人能像你一样冲下山坡。
There are circles where that's a very positive thing. We're not in one. That's really funny. I will never forget that. I will never forget that. Are you able to bike in New York? No, there's not as many bike riding opportunities, right? You're doing something different?
在某些圈子里，这绝对是一件非常正面的事。我们现在不在那种圈子里。这太搞笑了。我永远不会忘记这一点。我永远不会忘记这一点。你能在纽约骑自行车吗？不，那里骑自行车的机会没那么多，对吧？你在做别的吗？
Yeah. Everybody bikes in New York? Yeah, you can ride bikes in New York. You can ride along West Side Highway and then up West Side Highway pretty far. I'd be scared too though because of the traffic and people bikes in New York. Yeah, you can ride bikes in New York You can ride along West that highway and then up the West that highway pretty far Oh, yeah I'd be scared to though because of the traffic and people and the potholes right the roads are all torn to shit for I always Rode my bike. That's how we go around. No, but not these kinds of bikes. These kinds of bikes are like, you know
对。纽约每个人都骑自行车吗？对，你可以在纽约骑自行车。你可以沿着西区公路骑，然后沿着西区公路骑很远。不过我还是会害怕，因为交通状况和人们在纽约骑自行车。对，你可以在纽约骑自行车，你可以沿着西区公路骑，然后沿着西区公路骑很远。哦，对。不过我还是会害怕，因为交通状况、人群还有那些路坑，对吧？路都被毁得稀烂，为了我一直骑自行车。我们就是这么出行的。不，但不是这种自行车。这种自行车就像，你知道的
No, no, no, I wrote sports car Level performance tires and and you go over one little bump and they'll pop That well there's sometimes we where like we would my friends We'd go in the Central Park, right? Then you take the West Side Highway and then you'd have to cut in and when you cut in That's when you have to deal with about probably I don't know 15 blocks of pretty heavy traffic Because it's the center of Manhattan and then you get in the Central Park and you do the loops It's still crazy there too because they're depending on the time there's all these people walking crossing and all that stuff. Yeah people
不，不，不，我骑的是跑车级别的性能轮胎，只要轧到一个小坑就会爆胎。哦，有时我们会，就像我和朋友们会去中央公园，对吧？然后你走西区公路，接着你得插进支路，当你插进支路时，那就是你得应付大约，我不知道，15个街区非常拥堵的交通的时候，因为那是曼哈顿的中心，然后你进入中央公园，你在里面兜圈子。那里面也还是很疯狂，因为根据时间的不同，有各种各样的人在步行、过马路以及诸如此类的事情。对，人们
tricycles and wagons. Even on the weekend when they shut down the roads and stuff you got like a million ding-dongs and everybody's like tripping on acid for the first time in their life. Let's go trip on acid in Central Park. People are like that's where I did it. I'd give anything to hang out with a million ding-dongs. Yeah. I know you would. Oh Sean let's take a minute. It's like a ball pit. Sean, if you could fill a ball pit with any snack, what would it be? Oh my God.
三轮车和大篷车。甚至在周末封路的时候，你也会遇到大概一百万个笨蛋，每个人都像是在嗑他们人生中的第一口迷幻药。我们去中央公园嗑迷幻药吧。人们就像，那就是我干过这事的地方。我愿意付出一切去和一百万个笨蛋厮混。对。我知道你会的。哦，肖恩，我们花点时间吧。这就像个球池。肖恩，如果你能用任何零食填满一个球池，那会是什么？哦，天哪。
If you could fill a ball pit with any snack, what would it be? Just ask the great descender. Spaghetti. Old snacky descender wants to know what you'd fill your ball pit with. Jake, what I was gonna ask you was, because we're talking about cycling, like high level,
如果你能用任何零食填满一个球池，那会是什么？去问问那个伟大的下坡高手。意大利面。老零食下坡高手想知道你会用什么来填满你的球池。杰克，我要问你的是，因为我们在谈论骑自行车，高水平的，
like not just, yeah, I used to ride my bike, but I like had a beat up piece of shit and not doing it for like necessarily to get in shape. And it occurs to me, obviously I've seen so many promos for your new movie where you look like you're gonna fucking beat the whole world up, Roadhouse, and it's unbelievable. It looks amazing.
不仅仅是，是的，我以前骑过自行车，但我骑的是一辆破破烂烂的破车，而且骑车不一定是为了保持身材。我突然想到，显然我看到过很多你的新电影的宣传片，你在里面看起来就像要把全世界都痛揍一顿，《公路硬汉》，这太不可思议了。看起来棒极了。
It's unbelievable. But this is not the first time he's been fucking stacked. He's pissed himself tight. I've seen you in shape before in other things, and every time I have nothing but envy, I'm like, this motherfucker looks so good. And then, what occurs to me is, have you, and now we're talking about cycling,
这太不可思议了。但这并不是他第一次身材这么棒了。他把自己练得紧绷绷的。我以前在其他作品里见过你保持身材的样子，每一次我都羡慕嫉妒恨，心想这王八蛋怎么能这么帅。然后，我突然想到，你有没有，既然我们现在在谈论骑自行车，
have you always been into fitness your whole life? Forget getting in shape for the movie and being a super ripped fighter and crazy. Have you always been into exercising, staying mobile, playing sports, doing that shit? Yeah, always. I mean, my dad. Really? Yeah, my dad was super athletic. He still is. He would wake me up in the morning doing yoga in front of my bed. Oh boy. And then he'd be like, he'd be like, let's go for a run. Hey dad, can you turn the down dog just 180 for me when I get up please?
你一辈子都这么热爱健身吗？抛开为电影塑形、成为一个超级健硕的格斗家和疯狂训练不谈。你一直都喜欢锻炼、保持灵活性、做运动、搞这些名堂吗？对，一直都是。我是说，我爸。真的吗？对，我爸超级爱运动。他现在还是这样。他会在早晨把我叫醒，在我床前做瑜伽。哦，天哪。然后他会说，他会说，我们去跑步吧。嘿，爸爸，当我起床时，你能把下犬式转个180度吗？
I don't want to be bulldogged, right? When I get out of bed. Bulldogged. It's a technique of waking one up. Yeah. But like it was definitely, it was like, it was always perpendicular.
我可不想一醒来就被斗牛犬式压制，对吧？当我从床上起来的时候。斗牛犬式。这是一种把人叫醒的技术。对。但这绝对是，它总是垂直的。
Let's just, it was never, it was just FYI. He's a kind guy. I didn't have a lot of space in the front of the bed from my room as growing up. So he used what he had. But he would wake me up and we'd run and he was always very physical. He always sort of would. Like I remember we do like maybe a mile and a half run when I was a kid and he was always
咱们就，它从来不是，这只是顺便告诉你。他是个好人。我小时候床前没有太多的空间。所以他有什么就用什么。但他会叫醒我，我们去跑步，他一直都非常喜欢运动。他总是会。我记得当我还是个孩子的时候，我们会跑大约一英里半，他总是
so encouraging. And then by the time we got to the end of the last block, he would always be like, you gotta, this hurts me, you gotta run, you gotta sprint, like sprint this last block. And we'd run and then we'd run up the driveway. Remember the driveway, we'd just like, I'd be dying, we'd be like, go, go, go, he'd always let me win. And so, wow. Interesting. Yeah.
那么鼓励人。然后当我们跑到最后一个街区的尽头时，他总是会说，你得，这让我很难受，你得跑，你得冲刺，就像在最后一个街区冲刺一样。然后我们跑过去，然后我们冲上车道。还记得那个车道吗，我们就那样，我快累死了，我们就像，冲，冲，冲，他总是让我赢。所以，哇。很有意思。对。
We have this about Sean, I guess Sean's dad was really good at running too. He'd just try to do it before Sean got up and it would be in a car. It was just one direction. It was just one direction. It would be descending. He'd call for when he got to...
关于肖恩，我们也有过这样的经历，我猜肖恩的爸爸也很擅长跑步。他只是会在肖恩起床前跑步，而且是在车里。那只是单向的。那只是单向的。他在到达……时会大喊。
Running away. No, that's interesting. I used to run with my dad every single morning too. Did you really? Yeah, he'd wake me up every single morning and then I got old enough where I... You were an old kid? Yeah, and I'd start to sort of like complain
逃跑。不，这挺有意思的。我以前也每天早上都跟爸爸一起跑步。真的吗？对，他每天早上都把我叫醒，然后我长大了点，我……你是个老小孩？对，当我叫醒他时，我开始有点抱怨，
when he'd wake me up and start to say, no, I'm gonna sleep in this morning. And I was old enough where he'd say, well, all right, goodbye. And then so it stopped for a while. But then like everything you learn from your parents, you end up revisiting it and absorbing it when you're older.
开始说，不，我今天早上要多睡一会儿。我长大了，他就会说，好吧，再见。然后就停了一阵子。但就像你从父母那里学到的一切一样，当你长大了，你最终会重新审视并吸收它们。
Like now I run every day and I listen to classical music every day and I'm becoming my father, which is great. That's so interesting. You know, my brother, my oldest brother, because I didn't have the time. What's the opposite of interesting? Sorry.
就像现在我每天跑步，每天听古典音乐，我正在变成我父亲，这太棒了。太有趣了。你知道，我哥哥，我最大的哥哥，因为我没有时间。有什么词是“有趣”的反义词？抱歉。
Sorry. I was going to actually say that's sort of like a preface to what I was going to say, but then I just stopped and then when it stopped, it was like, oh, that sounded like, that was definitely not interesting. I got the boring handle. I got you. No, because I was going to say it's interesting
抱歉。我本来想说这有点像我要说的话的序言，但我突然停了下来，当它停下来的时候，就觉得，哦，听起来像，那绝对是一点也不有趣。我落了个无聊的头衔。我懂了。不，因为我要说的是这很有趣，
because my dad loves classical music and likes to exercise too, so there you go. We should hook them up. We should. That's wild. We absolutely should. Sorry, I asked that just not related at all to what we're talking about.
因为我爸也喜欢古典音乐和锻炼，所以你看。我们应该让他们俩认识一下。我们应该。太疯狂了。我们绝对应该。抱歉，我问那个问题跟我们聊的东西完全无关。
Go ahead, Sean, you had a question? No, I was just going to say, my brother used to wake me up at like four in the morning just to work on my legs because I was so skinny. Yeah, oh. So, Jake. Squats and stuff?
说吧，肖恩，你有什么问题？不，我只是想说，我哥哥以前经常在凌晨四点把我叫醒，只为了锻炼我的腿，因为我太瘦了。噢，原来如此。所以，杰克。深蹲什么的？
Wait, wait, wait. Yeah, just legs. Wait, wait, wait. Four in the morning. Wait, just legs? Every morning, just legs? Can we get another shot at that sentence? Can we just start again?
等等，等等，等等。对，就只是练腿。等等，等等。凌晨四点。等等，就练腿？我们能重新说一遍那句话吗？我们能重新开始吗？
Can we? It's true, it's true, it's true. That's like not okay. I know, I was exhausted. Every day. What are you saying? It's just legs. Okay, so. What are you talking about? I exhausted. Every day. What are you doing? It's just legs. Okay, so.
行吗？真的，真的，真的。这简直太离谱了。我知道，我筋疲力尽。每天。你在说什么？就是练腿。好吧，所以。你在说什么？我累垮了。每天。你在干什么？就是练腿。好吧，所以。
What are you talking about? I wanna know this thing, and by the way, I'm gonna ask all the boring. Yeah, you have him do squats in the middle of the night. By the way, have you seen Sean's biceps lately? I mean, this is honest. I gave his little arm a squeeze, what, Sunday. It's, Will, it's almost as big as yours.
你在说什么？我想知道这件事，顺便问一句，我要问所有无聊的。对，你让他大半夜做深蹲。顺便问一句，你最近看过肖恩的二头肌吗？我是说，说实话。我周日捏了一下他的小胳膊，怎么说呢。威尔，它几乎跟你的一样大。
He's stacked. Sean is like crazy built. squeeze what Sunday, it's almost as big as yours. He's stacked. Sean is like crazy built. I worked out at times. People cut me, because I'm in the Gyllenhaal category, but a lot of people refer to me, they call me JG on the side. JG. But Sean, are you fucking, are you lifting?
他练得太壮了。肖恩的体格简直夸张。捏了一下，什么，周日，它几乎跟你的一样大。他练得太壮了。我有时候也锻炼。人们觉得我很厉害，因为我是吉伦哈尔级别的，但很多人私下里管我叫JG。JG。但是肖恩，你他妈的，你也在举铁吗？
What's going on? No, I worked out for 20 years, like really hard, and then I was just, now I'm exhausted, now I just eat. Look, I have a bunch of questions for Jake Gyllenhaal. No, please. Okay, sorry. Sorry you don't want to talk about your physique. No, so Jake, I'm going to ask you boring questions
怎么回事？不，我锻炼了20年，练得超级刻苦，然后我只是，现在我累了，现在我只负责吃。听着，我对杰克·吉伦哈尔有一堆问题。不，请便。好吧，抱歉。抱歉你不想谈论你的身材。不，所以杰克，我要问你一些无聊的问题，
that I'm sure you've answered all before, but I did not know this thing about the noble, like nobility, Swedish thing. What's going on with that? I don't really know. I don't know. It's a pretty convoluted story that I've been told too and that I've heard.
我确信你以前都回答过，但我真的不知道关于贵族、瑞典血统的这件事。这到底是怎么回事？我其实也不知道。我不知道。这是一个非常曲折的故事，这也是别人告诉我并让我听到的。
We, I do, I'm a descendant from some form of Swedish nobility there. Yeah, that's about all. Your great-great-grandfather was like. Did you find this out doing one of the heritage tests? No, I've known it. We have like a coat of arms, you know, like... What?
我们，我的确，我是某种瑞典贵族的后代。对，差不多就是这样。你的曾曾祖父就像是。你是通过做基因检测发现这一点的吗？不，我一直都知道。我们有一个家族纹章，你知道，就像……什么？
Yeah, we have like a coat of arms and... That's cool. But I don't think he was really... I've done a little bit of digging. For a long time I thought that he was a great... like a king, you know, like a descendant. I was descended from like that kind of royalty. Right. But more and more as I did research, I realized that it was, he actually was like a cataloger and collector of beetles.
对，我们有一个家族纹章和……太酷了。但我认为他其实并不是……我稍微深挖了一下。很长一段时间里，我都以为他是一个伟大的人物……就像一个国王，你知道的，就像后代。我是那种皇室的后代。没错。但随着我做越来越多的研究，我意识到，实际上，他是一个甲虫的编目员和收集者。
And he worked for... Really? Yeah, I think so. Oh boy. Like a hoarder? Yeah, sort of a form of hoarder. No, I mean, he collected them, he pinned them, you know, he was like, you know, those beautiful, you beautiful, those things that they do.
他为……真的吗？对，我想是的。哦，天哪。就像一个囤积狂？对，算是某种形式的囤积狂。不，我是说，他收集它们，把它们钉起来，你知道的，就像，你知道的，他们做的那种精美的艺术品。
But he was a scientist, I guess, and then he was knighted for his scientific work. Yeah, and then I think that's how that's. Now how much time have you spent there in Sweden? Anything at all? I have never been to Sweden. Excellent. What?
但他是个科学家，我猜，然后他因为科学研究而被封为爵士。对，然后我想这就是这样。那你花在瑞典的时间有多少？去过一点吗？我从来没去过瑞典。太棒了。什么？
I have never been to Sweden. Do you have any desire to? It's great. I do, I'd wanna go there for Christmas. I have never been to Sweden. Excellent. What? I have never been to Sweden. Do you have any desire to? It's great. I do, I'd want to go there for Christmas. I've been a few times. And? It's amazing, right? It's amazing, it's amazing, it's incredible.
我从来没去过瑞典。你有什么愿望想去吗？那里的景色很棒。我有，我想去那里过圣诞节。我从来没去过瑞典。太棒了。什么？我从来没去过瑞典。你有什么愿望想去吗？那里的景色很棒。我有，我想去那里过圣诞节。我去过几次。然后呢？那里的景色太棒了，对吧？太棒了，太棒了，简直不可思议。
Do you have family there, Jake? I have extended family there, but I don't know them. There was a man named Herman Gyllenhaal, who actually I met, who came over from from Sweden that was in contact with my dad. This is not the bug man. It's not the bug man, but he is a descendant of the bug. Yeah. And he came and visited us and he was like, he was the one who tried to bring us all together, Americans and Swedish Gyllenhaals.
你在那儿有家人吗，杰克？我在那儿有远亲，但我不认识他们。有一个叫赫尔曼·吉伦哈尔（Herman Gyllenhaal）的人，我实际上见过他，他从瑞典远道而来，一直在和我爸爸联系。这不是那个抓虫子的人。这不是那个抓虫子的人，但他确实是那个抓虫子的人的后代。对。他来拜访过我们，他就像，他是那个试图把我们所有人——美国和瑞典的吉伦哈尔家族聚在一起的人。
I have some distant family in England that I haven't seen since I was a tiny, tiny kid and others that I've never even met. And I feel guilty about that, I think, but then it's also like, there would be, if you went down that lane, there would be hundreds, potentially, of people that you are somewhat related to that you have not yet met. And how do you guys feel about that? Well, I was gonna say, and I don't,
我在英国有一些远亲，自我很小很小的时候起就没见过他们了，还有一些我甚至从未谋面。我觉得对此挺内疚的，我想，但与此同时，这也意味着，如果你顺着这条线查下去，可能会有成百上千你有着某种血缘关系但从未谋面的人。你们对此有什么看法？嗯，我正要说，而且我没有，
I want you to take this the right way, Jamie. Here it comes, here it comes. No, I do. But if you think about it, if you think about it, you're a person who's in the public eye and so obviously they probably know who you are, especially if they share your name, they could get in touch with you if they wanted to.
我希望你能以正确的方式理解这一点，杰米。来了，来了。不，我是认真的。但如果你仔细想想，如果你仔细想想，你是一个公众人物，所以显然他们可能知道你是谁，特别是如果他们和你有相同的姓氏，如果他们想的话，完全可以联系你。
Oh, and they have it. I agree with that. So it's on them. Thank you, transferring guilt. Yeah. Sean, Sean, real question, real question. What do you think your dad's new name is? Can we talk about what a great descender Jason is for a second?
哦，他们确实联系了。我同意这一点。所以这得怪他们。谢谢你，成功转移了负罪感。对。肖恩，肖恩，严肃的问题，严肃的问题。你觉得你爸爸的新名字叫什么？我们能谈谈杰森是一个多么伟大的下坡高手吗？
Cause I feel like we moved off that. I really feel like we should go back to that. Yeah, I just wanna, I actually do have a compliment here. And it's actually, I wanna say that like, I was so profan, it is scary to go down a hill really fast. It really is when you're on a bike. It's not like, it's not for the faint of heart. I can't believe we're going back on the bike.
因为我觉得我们已经离开这个话题了。我真的觉得我们应该回到那个话题上去。对，我只是想，我其实在这里有一个赞美。实际上我想说的是，我太深刻地体会到了，从山上飞驰而下真的很吓人。骑自行车的时候确实如此。这可不是，这不是胆小鬼能干的。我真不敢相信我们又聊回自行车了。
And I realize what a badass he is. I just don't think I've ever fallen before. I think I just need to fall once and I'll be riding the brakes. Yeah, but I was like, this guy's nuts. Like you were going so fast. I remember just being like, whoa, he's gone. Like no concept of speed.
我意识到他是个多么狠的角色。我只是觉得我从来没有摔过车。我想我只需要摔一次，就会开始捏刹车了。对，但当时我想，这家伙疯了。你当时骑得太快了。我只记得当时心里想：哇，他没影了。完全没有速度的概念。
Are you going down Loma Vista? Are you going down Colmore? I feel like Moholland. We went down Moholland. I remember there were cars. It was crazy. You were just like, oh, that's right. Right by the Hollywood Bowl.
你当时是骑车下洛马维斯塔（Loma Vista）吗？你是在下科尔摩（Colmore）吗？我觉得是穆赫兰大道。我们当时在下穆赫兰大道。我记得路上有车。太疯狂了。你当时就像是，哦，对了。就在好莱坞碗剧场旁边。
Yeah. I was like, it was crazy. It was so fast. It was so dangerous. And I was deeply impressed. I really was. You know what's scary? I know a few boys, a few guys, I sound like Sean,
对。我就觉得，这太疯狂了。太快了。太危险了。我深感震惊。真的。你知道什么很可怕吗？我认识几个男孩，几个家伙，我听起来像肖恩了，
I know a few guys who got really into cycling, including my brother-in-law, Eddie, and a couple other guys I know who got severely injured doing that kind of super, like really. Well, and that's why, Jay, correct me if I'm wrong, that's why one shaves their legs, right? In the anticipation of the inevitability. How does that stop your head from getting crushed?
我认识几个迷上骑自行车的家伙，包括我的连襟埃迪，还有其他几个我知道的朋友，他们在进行那种超级疯狂、真正激烈的骑行时受了重伤。嗯，这也是为什么，杰伊，如果我没说错的话，这就是为什么人们要刮腿毛，对吧？为了预防不可避免的摔车。这怎么能阻止你的脑袋被压碎呢？
You mean generally that's why anyone shaves their legs? Or you mean four? No, bicyclists, because you are going to fall. You're going to fall and you're gonna slide across the asphalt and if you don't have any hair on your legs or arms, the skin does not ball up as much and cleaning it becomes less painful. Is that, that's correct, right?
你是说通常这就是为什么任何人都要刮腿毛？还是指四号？不，自行车手，因为你迟早会摔车。你会摔倒，然后在沥青路面上滑行，如果你的腿上或胳膊上没有毛发，皮肤就不会揉成一团，清理起来也就没那么痛苦。是这样，对吧？
I've heard a lot of things, I think that's true. I also think like, I mean, being aerodynamic, which is sort of a weird thing, but I think there's like, there are a lot of superstitions. Like I've heard superstitions from cyclists who are like, they are allowed to eat cheese but it can't be melted because it has like more calories or something.
我听过很多说法，我觉得这是真的。我还觉得，我是说，为了符合空气动力学，这虽然听起来有点怪，但我觉得有很多迷信的说法。比如我听过一些自行车手的迷信说法，他们被允许吃奶酪，但不能是融化的，因为那样卡路里更高什么的。
I don't know, there's all these weird things. So I don't know, I mean, I, I, but I do think also if you're going to wear spandex that tight, like, you know, you don't want to have like hair pants, you know what I mean? Oh, you mean the hair coming through the spandex? Yeah, not a good line. And also just like hair pants,
我不知道，有各种各样奇怪的讲究。所以我不知道，我是说，我，但我确实也觉得，如果你要穿那么紧的氨纶骑行裤，你知道的，你肯定不想长着“毛裤”，你明白我的意思吗？哦，你是说毛发透过紧身裤露出来？对，那画面不太美观。而且就像毛裤一样，
like it's just like spandex and hair, you know what I mean? Maybe that's something, you know? But yes, the scab thing is true. I thought it was excessive, Jay, because I remember you talking when you first got it, but I thought it was excessive when you started getting Brazilians as well,
就像紧身裤加毛发，你知道我的意思吗？也许那是一种时尚，你懂的？不过是的，结痂的说法是真的。我觉得这有点夸张了，杰伊，因为我记得你刚开始骑车时聊过这个，但我觉得你开始做巴西式比基尼脱毛时就太夸张了，
because I was like, how is this helping? And I saw that when you were descending, and I was like, that was not necessary. I'm gonna go ahead and ride the saddle. Yeah, I don't need to arch and offer. I can't do all that. No. Because right as you sped off into literally warp speed, to arch and offer. I can't believe you did all that. No?
因为我想，这到底有什么用？我看到你下坡的时候，心想这完全没必要。我还是老老实实骑我的车座吧。对，我不需要拱起身体去迎合。我可做不到那些。不。因为就在你像曲速飞行一样飞驰出去的瞬间，去拱起身体迎合。我真不敢相信你做了那些。不？
Right as you sped off into like literally warp speed, I was like what? Well that was enough. You don't know how you're going to land. You don't know what's going to hit the pavement first. And who's going to see what. Right. It's needless to say, I'm no longer on the bike.
就在你像曲速飞行一样飞驰出去的瞬间，我心想，什么？这就足够了。你根本不知道自己会怎么着陆。你不知道什么会先撞击路面。谁又会看到什么。没错。不用说，我再也不骑自行车了。
I've sold the bike, Jake, I'm embarrassed to say. What? But I still have a huge drawer full of the funny outfits that I'm happy to sell to you on a very, very fair rate. Jake, I wanna know about you growing up. Jake, are you the right size? Would you fit into an old man's extra small? I did invite Jason just this year to a bike trip, actually.
我已经把自行车卖了，杰克，说实话我都觉得不好意思。什么？但我还有一个大抽屉，里面装满了那些滑稽的行头，我很乐意以非常非常公道的价格卖给你。杰克，我想了解一下你成长的经历。杰克，你的尺码对吗？你能穿老年人的加小码吗？其实我今年还邀请了杰森去进行一次自行车旅行。
I reached out to you and invited you to a bike trip. It sounded very, very, very good. Can you say where you went? This was overseas, wasn't it? Yeah, yeah, yeah. I went to the Alps. Yeah, I went to the... Wow.
我联系了你，邀请你参加一次自行车旅行。听起来非常非常非常棒。你能说说你们去哪儿了吗？这是在海外，对吧？对，对，对。我去了阿尔卑斯山。对，我去了……哇。
I was in the Pyrenees, yeah. We climbed like... Climbed the Alpe d'Huez, we climbed the Gloubié, we climbed Mont Ventoux, we did this crazy six-day trip. This guy's a specimen, you guys. Wait, wait, wait. You went to the Pyrenees? You didn't go to Andorra, did you?
我去了比利牛斯山，对。我们爬了……爬了阿尔卑斯于埃兹山（Alpe d'Huez），爬了格兰维（Gloubié），爬了旺图山（Mont Ventoux），我们进行了一次疯狂的六天旅行。这家伙简直是个超人，伙计们。等等，等等，等等。你去了比利牛斯山？你没去安道尔，对吧？
It's the one place I want to go is Andorra. Yeah, no, it was... We were in like... We crossed over the Pyrenees, you didn't go to Andorra, did you? It's the one place I wanna go is Andorra. Yeah, and it was, we were in like, we crossed over the Pyrenees and we were in Provence and then we climbed, the last climb we did was Mont Ventoux which is like, I think it's about 2,100 kilometers and then it's like 11% incline the whole time. Which was one of the most physically challenging things I've ever done and also such a incredible experience.
我最想去的地方就是安道尔。对，不，那是……我们在像……我们穿过了比利牛斯山，你没去安道尔，对吧？我最想去的地方就是安道尔。对，而且，我们在像……我们穿过了比利牛斯山，然后到了普罗旺斯，接着我们爬山，我们爬的最后一座山是旺图山，那座山，我想大概有2100米高，而且整个过程坡度大约是11%。那是我经历过最具有身体挑战性的事情之一，也是一段令人难以置信的经历。
And really like, it was, yeah, it's sort of inexplicable. things I've ever done and also such an incredible experience. And really like it was, yeah, it's sort of inexplicable. Speaking of like tripping, you just by the end, you're just pushing to the... Euphoria. Yeah. And did you make it okay? Like comfortably? Did you throw up afterwards?
真的就像，它是，是的，有点难以言表。我经历过最具有身体挑战性的事情之一，也是一段令人难以置信的经历。真的就像，它是，是的，有点难以言表。说到像产生幻觉，你到最后，你只是在拼尽全力……达到欣快感。对。你顺利完成了吗？感觉舒服吗？你之后吐了吗？
Was your saddle aching? The first one we did out the Alptuez, I've ridden before, once before. I rode it like maybe 15 years ago. And I had been working, so I hadn't been riding my bike a whole lot, but I had assumed that I'd be like, okay, I kind of know. And one of the things that I think is really important
你的车座硌得慌吗？我们第一次骑的阿尔卑斯于埃兹山，我以前骑过一次。大约15年前我骑过。我一直在工作，所以没有经常骑自行车，但我自以为，我还可以，我大概还记得。我觉得非常重要的一点
is just more mental, like how much pain can you handle? Really that, and so I was like, oh, okay, I'll be fine, right? And when I arrived, we had like guides, we had two guys, ex-pros, they were great guys, and then my good friend was with me, and he had been training like secretly, and I had been trying to get on a Peloton, like for,
其实更多是心理上的，你能承受多少痛苦？真的是这样，所以我当时想，哦，好吧，我会没事的，对吧？等我到达时，我们有向导，有两个前职业车手，他们人非常好，然后我的好朋友也和我一起去了，他一直在秘密训练，而我一直在试着骑Peloton，就像，
I had just been like desperately trying, I hadn't been on a bike, I was just like, for a week I was like, I'm just gonna go really hard on Peloton, I'll be fine. Not applicable. When I arrived off the train in France, the two ex-pros looked at my friend, they're like, well you're ready.
我只是拼命地尝试，我之前根本没怎么骑车，我只是，有一周时间我心想，我只要在Peloton上狠狠地练就行了，我会没事的。完全不适用。当我从法国的火车站出来时，那两个前职业车手看着我的朋友，他们说，好吧，你准备好了。
And I was like, wait, what? And so the Alpe d'Huez, we got up there and I bonked halfway up the Alpe d'Huez. Meaning you just ran out of gas? I just ran out of gas because you can't, like what happens is your body just can't, you just run out of glucose. Oh And we will be right back
然后我说，等等，什么？于是我们就上了阿尔卑斯于埃兹山，结果我在爬阿尔卑斯于埃兹山到一半的时候“爆缸”了。意思是你的油耗尽了？我就是油耗尽了，因为你不能，情况是你的身体根本吃不消，你的葡萄糖耗尽了。哦，我们马上回来。
Smart let's get support from car shield many of us spend a good chunk of time in the car whether you're driving to work or Planning a fun road trip with friends. You want to make sure your car is in top shape to handle any drive But if you have been in the same car for years, you might worry about future breakdowns. Don't let the stress of paperwork or headaches of repairs keep you from getting where you need to be. With CarShield, all you need to do is give them a call, choose the mechanic, and they handle the rest. CarShield plans provide protection on up to 5,000 major parts and systems, including big
明智之举，让我们来看看CarShield提供的支持。我们很多人在车里度过了相当长的时间，无论是开车去上班，还是计划和朋友来一场有趣的公路旅行。你都想确保你的车处于最佳状态，以应付任何行程。但如果你开同一辆车已经好几年了，你可能会担心未来的抛锚问题。别让繁琐的文书工作压力或维修的头疼问题阻碍你到达想去的地方。有了CarShield，你只需要打个电话，选择修理厂，剩下的就交由他们处理。CarShield的套餐为多达5000个主要零部件和系统提供保障，包括大
ticket items like your transmission, engine, and even your entertainment system. Plus, plans include exclusive access to Car Shield's concierge service, as well as 24-7 roadside assistance, and help with flat or damaged tires, lockouts, and rental car options. With Car Shield, road trips have never been easier. Avoid the hassle of costly car repairs with Car Shield.
件物品，如变速箱、发动机，甚至你的娱乐系统。此外，套餐还包括独家使用CarShield的礼宾服务，以及24/7路边援助，并协助处理爆胎或轮胎损坏、车门反锁以及提供租车选项。有了CarShield，公路旅行变得从未如此轻松。使用CarShield，避免昂贵汽车维修的麻烦。
Visit carshield.com slash smartless and save 20% today. Again, that's carshield.com slash smartlis and save 20% today. Again, that's carshield.com slash smartlis to save 20%. Visit carshield.com slash smartlis to lock in your price today. This episode of SmartList is brought to you in part by Skinny Pop Popcorn. Looking for some excitement? Well, do that on your own time. But in the meantime, check out Skinny Pop's new Cheddar Jalapeno Popcorn. Made with real cheddar cheese and a pop of jalapeno, this new flavor is sure to spice up your daily snacking routine. Listen, I love Skinny Pop popcorn and look, I request this is actually a true thing.
访问carshield.com/smartless，今天即可节省20%。再次强调，网址是carshield.com/smartless，今天即可节省20%。再次强调，访问carshield.com/smartless可节省20%。访问carshield.com/smartless，今天就锁定你的价格。本期SmartList节目部分内容由Skinny Pop爆米花为您呈献。寻找一些刺激？好吧，在你自己闲暇的时候去寻找吧。但与此同时，来看看Skinny Pop全新的切达墨西哥胡椒味爆米花吧。采用真正的切达干酪和少许墨西哥胡椒制作，这种新口味肯定会为你的日常零食时间增添一些趣味。听着，我非常喜欢Skinny Pop爆米花，听着，我要求这其实是一件真事。
You know, sometimes when you're going out on a job in the line of work I'm in, which is obviously entertainment, and no, I don't work for the government in some super highly classified capacity. And I can't confirm and or deny anything. The point is this, they asked me if I want stuff when I'm at work, like as part of my refreshment selection.
你知道，有时当你出去工作时，在我从事的行当里，显然是娱乐业，不，我不是为政府从事某种超级绝密的工作。我也既不证实也不否认任何事情。重点是这个，他们在工作时问我想不想要点东西，作为茶歇精选的一部分。
Skinny Pop popcorn is always there. That is a true story. Skinny Pop is light and tasty and perfect for any occasion, whether you're on the go, staving off boredom or unwinding after a long day. A deliciously simple combination of popcorn, oil and salt, every bite of their perfectly popped original popcorn leaves you wanting more. In addition to the original popcorn, Skinny Pop offers a variety of delicious flavors, ranging from white cheddar to sweet and salty kettle, all perfectly popped, endlessly delicious. Let me tell you something also, that salty kettle, forget it. Just forget it.
Skinny Pop爆米花总是在那里。这是一个真实的故事。Skinny Pop轻盈美味，完美适合任何场合，无论你是在路上、摆脱无聊还是在漫长的一天后放松身心。作为爆米花、油和盐的美味简单组合，他们完美爆开的原味爆米花的每一口都让你回味无穷。除了原味爆米花，Skinny Pop还提供各种美味口味，从白切达干酪到香甜咸味水壶煮爆米花，全部完美爆开，无尽美味。我还要告诉你一件事，那个咸味水壶煮的，别提了。简直别提了。
You're going to be on a delicious ride to fantastic town. Shop skinny pop now. SmartList is brought to you in part by Audible. Audible, it lets you enjoy all your audio entertainment in one app. You always find the best of what you love or something new to discover. They offer an incredible selection of audiobooks across every genre from bestsellers and new releases to celebrity memoirs, mysteries and thrillers, motivation, wellness, business and more.
你将开启一段通往美味小镇的美妙旅程。立即选购Skinny Pop。SmartList部分内容由Audible为您呈献。Audible让你在一个应用程序中享受所有音频娱乐。你总能找到你最爱的最佳内容或发现新事物。他们跨越所有流派提供令人难以置信的有声书选择，从畅销书和新书发布到名人回忆录、悬疑与惊悚片、励志、健康、商业等等。
It's just the list is, I'm not going to say endless because that'd be misleading, but it's long. Audible is your destination for thrilling audio entertainment with highly anticipated new releases and next listen recommendations for every type of thriller listener. As an Audible member, you can choose one title a month to keep
这份名单简直，我不会说它是无边无际的，因为那会产生误导，但它真的很长。Audible是您体验惊心动魄的音频娱乐的目的地，这里有备受期待的新书发布以及针对各种类型惊悚片爱好者的下一本收听推荐。作为Audible会员，您可以从整个目录中选择每月保留一本标题，
from the entire catalog, including the latest bestsellers and new releases. I like to read quite a bit, and so I don't do a ton of listening to audiobooks, but when I do, I've done it a few times and I've really enjoyed it. And one of the ones that I listened to on Audible was The Power of Now by Eckhart Tolle. And here's a fun little addition. He narrates it himself. How about that? There's another one that I'll recommend for you to read, which is Heat 2. Remember Heat, the movie?
包括最新的畅销书和新书发布。我挺喜欢阅读的，所以我不会听太多有声书，但偶尔听的时候，我听过好几次，而且真的很享受。我在Audible上听过的一本书是埃克哈特·托利（Eckhart Tolle）的《当下的力量》（The Power of Now）。这里还有一个有趣的小彩蛋。是他自己亲自配音的。觉得怎么样？还有另一本书我向大家推荐阅读，那就是《盗火线2》（Heat 2）。还记得电影《盗火线》吗？
You loved it. Well, Heat 2 came out as a book and narrated by my pal, the great Peter Giles. It's a fantastic listen. That's obviously I listened to it because my buddy Pete Giles, but I tell you what, it is fantastic. New members can try Audible for free for 30 days. Visit audible.com slash smartless or text smartless to 500-500. That's audible.com slash smartless or text smartless to 500-500 to try Audible free for
你超爱它。好吧，《盗火线2》作为一本书出版了，并由我的好朋友、伟大的彼得·盖尔斯（Peter Giles）配音。这是一本非常精彩的有声书。我听这个显然是因为我的好哥们皮特·盖尔斯，但我告诉你，它真的太精彩了。新会员可以免费体验Audible 30天。访问audible.com/smartless，或发送短信smartless至500-500。网址是audible.com/smartless，或发送短信smartless至500-500，即可免费体验Audible 30天。
30 days. Audible.com slash smartless And now back to the show Have you ever ridden with Lance Armstrong Yes, and how'd you do? Did you keep up? No, I did not know I mean like when it when he wanted to let me keep up I kept up, right? I watched one of those one of those doc series about the guys climbing the Alps that was on I mean, like, when he wanted to let me keep up, I kept up. Right. I watched one of those Docs series
audible.com/smartless现在让我们回到节目中你曾经和兰斯·阿姆斯特朗（Lance Armstrong）一起骑过车吗？是的，你骑得怎么样？你跟上了吗？没有，我没有。我是说，当他想让我跟上的时候，我确实跟上了，对吧？我去年在某个流媒体平台上看过一部关于这群人攀登阿尔卑斯山的纪录片系列。对，你告诉我了，我也看过。
about the guys climbing the Alps that was on one of the streaming services last year. Yeah, you told me that I watched that too. Yeah, and I think like, sort of 20 minutes less into the first one, I was like, mother fuck, this is hard. Like, how the fuck do you do it? The one thing I don't understand, Jake,
对，我想，大约看了第一集的前20分钟，我就想，他妈的，这太难了。这他妈到底是怎么做到的？有一点我实在不明白，杰克，
is why can't the seat be more comfortable? Why does it have to be so hard? Yeah. You know, because like you do lose circulation, it's so hard and things just go numb and it's not comfortable. Like if it could just be a little pad or maybe like a shearling top, you know, like a sheepskin.
为什么车座不能更舒服一点？为什么一定要这么硬？你知道的，因为你确实会血液循环不畅，太硬了，身体各处都会麻木，一点也不舒服。如果能稍微加个垫子，或者像羊皮绒那样，比如羊皮。
You can do that. You can do anything you want. There's no like rules. Jay, you should do a collab with Uggs. You can do a collab with Uggs, baby. Ooh. Sort of a back rest maybe even. And they have those too, man.
你可以那么做。你想怎么样都行。没有什么所谓的规则。杰克，你应该和Uggs合作一下。你可以和Uggs联名推出一款产品，宝贝。哦。甚至还可以加个靠背。他们也有那种东西，伙计。
Like you can do anything. There's no, there's no like, you're not like riding in the Tour de France. You can do whatever you want. I'm a soft guy, you know? Yeah, like, or even like something with an engine or like, you know, two seats and passengers. Or a rope like a something with an engine or like Passengers, you know a rope that's connected to an engine. Yeah
就像你可以做任何事。没有那种，没有那种，你又不是在骑环法自行车赛。你想干嘛就干嘛。我这人比较随性，你知道吗？对，比如说，甚至是那种带发动机的，或者像，你知道的，有两个座位能带乘客的。或者像是一根绳子，那种带发动机的，或者像乘客，你知道的，连着发动机的一根绳子。对
Like that flies in the sky and takes you places thinking of which what about those ebikes do you have one yet? Are we gonna talk for an hour about? Until we're done with all of it. No, no, no, I have a thousand questions. I know. Sean's like, I can see his face. He's like, oh my God, I asked one question about his Swedish noble. Enough of the bikes. Did I buy an e-bike? I have bought an e-bike. Yes. And you know there are e-bikes.
就像在天上飞，能带你去各处——说到这个，那些电动自行车怎么样？你有一辆了吗？我们是要花一小时来讨论吗？直到我们把这些全聊完。不，不，不，我有一千个问题。我知道。肖恩的表情写在脸上了，他一副“噢天哪，我只问了一个关于他有瑞典贵族血统的问题”的表情。自行车够了。我买电动自行车了吗？我确实买了一辆电动自行车。是的。而且你知道有那种电动自行车——
Like if you want to come on a trip, any of you guys want to come, you're not doing a good come a trip. I'm not going. If you want to come on the trip, no, for real. Like if you want to come, if you want to ride, regular, you can ride like just without. They also have e-bikes that are attached to like a heart rate.
就像如果你想来参加骑行，你们谁想来，你们这可不太行——来参加骑行。我不去。如果你想来参加骑行，说真的。如果你想来，如果你想骑，普通的，你可以就这么骑，不用……它们还有那种跟心率挂钩的电动自行车。
So you can choose your heart rate that you want to get to. So if you want like, and then stay at, and the bike will keep you at that place. Go away. What do you do about all, you just wear headphones to mute out the ridicule you're getting from the other riders? Like, I am just desperately, I really want people
所以你可以选择你想要达到的心率。如果你想要，然后保持在那个状态，自行车就会让你维持在那个心率。得了吧。那你该怎么应付所有这些，你只是戴着耳机来屏蔽其他骑行者的冷嘲热讽吗？就像，我真的非常非常渴望人们
to get on this trip and come because it's fun, but they don't believe it. You know, no one believes that they're on a trip. Where is it? Where is the trip? Well, they changed. Like, we're trying to find new cool places to... Not Hancock Park, Sean.
能加入这次骑行并一起来，因为这很有趣，但他们就是不信。你知道的，没人相信他们是在去骑行。在哪？骑行在哪？哦，它们变了。就像，我们在试图寻找新的酷地方去……不是汉考克公园，肖恩。
Okay, I'm sorry. You won't be there. All right, Sean, let's hear some of these bitching questions. Finally. Jake, welcome to the show. Jake has done a lot of theater, so Jake. Hold on, hold on, let me just, hold on. Reveal yourself.
好吧，对不起。你不会在那儿的。好了，肖恩，让我们听听这些刁钻的问题吧。总算开始了。杰克，欢迎来到节目。杰克演过很多戏剧，所以杰克。等等，等等，让我先，等等。露面吧。
Oh, hey. Jake O'Hall. Jake O'Hall. It's the Sean Hayes Show. Go ahead, Sean. So I wanna know about growing up and with your, because I think it's fascinating that you come from a family. Your dad's a director, your mom is this incredible writer,
噢，嘿。杰克·吉伦哈尔。杰克·吉伦哈尔。这里是《肖恩·海斯秀》。请说，肖恩。所以我想了解你成长经历，因为我觉得你的家庭背景太迷人了。你爸爸是导演，你妈妈是这位了不起的作家，
your sister is also, like, it's all, you're all killing it. So it's like, by the way, I had dinner with your mom at a mutual lawyer friend's house a million years ago, and I was much younger then, and I hadn't really written anything yet, and I expressed to your mom, God, you know, I wish I was a better writer, it's just so overwhelming to me,
你姐姐也是，总之，你们全家都太厉害了。所以就像，顺便说一句，一百年前我在一个共同的律师朋友家和你妈妈吃过晚饭，那时我年轻得多，还没写过什么东西，我向你妈妈表达说：“天哪，你知道的，我希望我能成为一个更好的作家，这一切对我来说太让人不知所措了，”
and I remember this, I'll never forget it. She said, the hardest part of writing is starting. And your mom said that to me, and I still remember it. Not that we hear that all the time, but that was the first time I ever heard anybody say it was from your mom. And so I took that and I started writing, and I wrote scripts and whatever, but that it was from your mom. And so I took that and I started writing and I wrote scripts and whatever,
我记得这个，我永远不会忘记。她说：“写作最难的部分就是开始。”你妈妈对我说了这句话，我至今仍记得。倒不是说我们不经常听到这句话，但这是我第一次听到任何人这么说，就是从你妈妈口中。所以我把这句话记在心里，开始写作，我写了剧本什么的，但那是因为你妈妈。所以我把这句话记在心里，开始写作，我写了剧本什么的，
but that was because of your mom. Holy shit. Jesus Christ. Wow. You're gonna lead with that. My mom will be actually so flattered by that. Yeah, what a memory. So it's just starting, it's the hard part?
但那都是因为你妈妈。卧槽。天呐。哇。你竟然以这个开场。我妈妈听到这个其实会非常受宠若惊的。对啊，多好的回忆。所以，只是开始，这是最难的部分？
Is that, fuck. I was just gonna ask Sean. But I hadn't heard that before. Sean, I was gonna ask every time you start, everything you think about my mom. Yeah, I mean, really apply it to anything I think. Weird question, Sean. No, it wasn't, he didn't even have a question mark on it.
是这样吗，操。我本想问肖恩的。不过我以前没听过这个。肖恩，我本想问，每次你开始——你脑子里想的都是我妈妈。对，我是说，真的可以套用到我脑子里的任何事。奇怪的问题，肖恩。不，这根本不是个问题，他连个问号都没用。
No question. This is how bad the Sean Hayes show is. I wanna... Thank you for listening to the Sean Hayes show. We just started and we ended. Thank you Naomi Foner. No, you know what, I will say, I will say... We just started and we ended. Thank you Naomi Foner. No, you know what?
没有问题。《肖恩·海斯秀》就是这么烂。我想……谢谢收听《肖恩·海斯秀》。我们刚开始就结束了。谢谢娜奥米·方纳。不，你知道吗，我要说，我要说……我们刚开始就结束了。谢谢娜奥米·方纳。不，你知道吗？
I will say, I will say. That's my mom's name by the way. Wait, what's your mom's name? Naomi Foner. So she, think about that. I will say, to Sean's credit, it is interesting to have something like that happen and that something that sticks with you and now you're on with the person JB. Yes, that's crazy to me.
我要说，我要说。顺便说一句，那是我妈妈的名字。等等，你妈妈叫什么名字？娜奥米·方纳。所以，想想看吧。我要说，有一说一，发生这样的事确实挺有意思的，有句话能一直伴随着你，而现在你正和这个人连线，JB。是的，这对我来说太疯狂了。
It is mildly interesting. However, the way Sean said it was so fucking boring. So, it could have been interesting. Will you come on the bike cycle trip? We'll talk so much shit about Sean. I'll talk shit about anybody. You don't have to go on a bike ride. It's a trip, you just listen to this.
这勉强算有趣。不过，肖恩说出来的方式他妈的太无聊了。所以，本来可以挺有趣的。你会来参加自行车骑行之旅吗？我们会狠狠吐槽肖恩的。我谁都会吐槽。你不用去骑自行车。这只是一次旅行，你听着就行。
But Sean, get us back on the rails, we're sorry. I will, I wanna know what it was like. I know, it shit about anybody. You don't have to go on a bike ride. You just listen to this. But Sean, get us back on the rails. We're sorry. I wanna know what it was like. I know, it's so hard. I wanna know what it was like. I mean, again, I say this all the time on the podcast. I grew up in Chicago with looking at Hollywood like this thing that was unachievable.
但肖恩，把我们拉回正轨吧，不好意思。会的，我想知道那是什么感觉。我知道，吐槽任何人。你不用去骑自行车。你听着就行。但肖恩，把我们拉回正轨吧。不好意思。我想知道那是什么感觉。我知道，这太难了。我想知道那是什么感觉。我是说，再次声明，我在播客里经常这么说。我在芝加哥长大，把好莱坞看作是一个遥不可及的存在。
So I came here with, so what was it like growing up? And I know you get asked this all the time, but I don't know the answer. Growing up around it, and then is, did you find that that's all you're talking about around the dinner table when your kids is the business, and how do you escape talking about other things, and you know? Jason, do you want to take this in tandem, so to speak?
所以我来到这里时——那么，成长经历是怎样的？我知道你经常被问到这个问题，但我不知道答案。在那种环境中长大，然后，你有没有发现，在餐桌上你们全家人讨论的全部都是这行里的事，你是怎么避免去聊其他事情的，你知道吗？杰森，你想顺着这个话题接着聊吗？
It is, I was just so curious to hear what your answer is gonna be, because I've got my, yeah, yeah. What was it, it's better, right? Gives you even more stuff to talk about around the dinner table? I think it's a double-edged sword. It is a double-edged sword, you know?
我是说，我只是很好奇想听听你的答案是什么，因为我也有我的，对，对。感觉怎么样，这样更好，对吧？让你在餐桌上有更多的话题可以聊？我觉得这是一把双刃剑。这确实是一把双刃剑，你知道的？
I think in a way it's amazing, because speaking of my mom, like, she taught me so much about all this stuff, you know, and how to find stuff that's good, and what's good, and when the dialogue's good. And then same, when I was a kid, my dad would, I'd play around, I'd joke, I was performing when I was really little, just joking around.
我觉得某种程度上这太棒了，因为说到我妈妈，她教了我很多关于这方面的知识，你知道的，以及如何发现好东西，什么是好的，什么时候对白是好的。还有同样地，当我还是个孩子的时候，我爸爸会，我会玩闹，我会开玩笑，我其实很小的时候就开始表演了，就是到处开玩笑。
And then he sort of would really encourage it and kind of understood me in that performance stuff. So there was outside of the kind of idea of like the advice and stuff and watching their careers and then saying, oh, you could go this way or that way, oh, don't do this, try that, which is a bit of a head start. Yeah. Well, how much of your own,
然后他会真的鼓励这种行为，并且某种程度上理解我身上的这种表演欲。所以在那种关于建议的想法之外，看着他们的职业生涯，然后说，噢，你可以走这条路或那条路，噢，别这么做，试试那个——这其实算是一个领先的起跑线。对。好吧，你有多少，
because a lot of people grow up with, and we take on points of view, sometimes our point of view is colored by our upbringing and our parents and what we, you know. Sometimes. Well, a lot of times. When you go into the same, but certainly vocationally, when you go into the same thing that your parents did,
因为很多人成长过程中，我们会接受各种观点，有时我们的观点会被我们的成长经历、我们的父母以及我们所经历的事所涂上色彩，你知道的。有时会。好吧，很多时候都会。当你进入同一个，但当然在职业上，当你进入和你父母相同的行业时，
do you now, do you look back and go like, oh, I see the influence of my mom or my dad speaking to me while I, when I look at a script, when I think about doing something, when I'm making a choice as an artist, if you will, do you recognize that? I try to, both good and bad, you know? I really do, I try as best as I can.
你现在回过头去看，会觉得“噢，当我看着一个剧本，当我考虑做某件事，当我作为一个艺术家做出选择时，我看到了我妈妈或我爸爸的声音在对我说”吗？作为一个艺术家，如果你愿意这么称呼的话，你能认出这种影响吗？我尽量去察觉，有好的也有坏的，你知道的？真的，我尽我最大努力去察觉。
I mean, what I do think is a lot of those things as we get to be a certain age become an unconscious thing, right? Yeah. You put them into experience and then you do things and you're lucky enough to make things and you keep doing it and then you try them out and then we get a tool belt and then we're using it and you know, and so they are a mix of that. I can't differentiate anymore really from what I've learned from them and what I've
我是说，我确实认为随着我们长到某个年纪，很多这样的事情会变成一种无意识的东西，对吧？是的。你把它们融入经历中，然后你去做事，如果你足够幸运能够创作作品，你就会一直做下去，然后你去尝试它们，接着我们拥有了工具箱，然后我们在使用它，你知道的，所以它们是这些东西的混合体。我真的再也分不清哪些是我从他们身上学到的，哪些是我从
learned from other people because I've been doing it from such a young age. Do they still give you input? Do they, when you work on something? Yeah, particularly like, particularly with writing, and even, you know, in development of things and things like that, my sister wrote her first screenplay and wrote and directed it, and to great success. And then she just wrote another one and she's directing it.
其他人那里学到的了，因为我从很小的时候就开始做这件事了。他们还会给你提供意见吗？当你创作某些东西的时候，他们会吗？会，特别是像，特别是在写作方面，甚至，你知道的，在事物的开发以及诸如此类的事情上，我姐姐写了她的第一个剧本，并且自编自导，取得了巨大的成功。然后她刚又写了一个剧本，现在由她来导演。
It's this amazing thing, so. And my mom is a big part of it. You know, my sister sends me the script, she sends my mom the script, my mom and her will talk through things. You know, she's a real mentor. And that is a massive thing to have in your back pocket. Yeah. And do you find, like, I think naturally any child
这真是件了不起的事，所以。而且我妈妈在其中扮演了很重要的角色。你知道的，我姐姐会把剧本发给我，也会发给我妈妈，我妈妈会和她一起讨论各种事情。你知道的，她是一位真正的导师。口袋里能有这样一位导师，真的是件了不起的事。对。你有没有发现，我觉得自然而然地，任何孩子
is always looking to impress their parents when they're tiny. And then as you grow older, you start to meet other adults, you become an adult yourself. But since you started with the entertainment industry and your parents were in it, do you find that they still occupy the major sort of North Star you kind of point your efforts towards
在他们很小的时候，总是想要给父母留下深刻的印象。然后随着你长大，你开始遇到其他成年人，你自己也成为了成年人。但既然你从娱乐产业开始，而且你的父母就在这个行业里，你有没有发现他们依然占据着主要的类似“北极星”的位置，指引着你努力的方向，
and look for their approval and their review of things? Do you know what I mean? I certainly do. I'm still sort of a small boy kind of looking for dad's approval because that's where it all started there. He taught me how to act, he taught me how to direct. And I like that, I like that I'm not over that.
并且寻求他们的认可和对事情的评价？你知道我的意思吗？我当然有这种感觉。我某种程度上仍然是个渴望得到父亲认可的小男孩，因为这一切就是从那里开始的。他教我如何演戏，他教我如何导演。我喜欢这样，我喜欢我还没摆脱这种心态。
Aren't we all? I mean, yeah, in one way or another, definitely. I think also though, there's a sense of just for me now, you know, because there's all that stuff, like work is so, it becomes like a big thing, you know, with all of our families, you know, if our parents are working, like, you hear about their work, right?
我们不都这样吗？我是说，是的，以这样或那样的方式，绝对是的。不过我也觉得，对我现在来说，你知道的，因为有所有这些事情，工作是如此，它变成了一件大事，你知道的，在我们所有的家庭里，如果我们父母在工作，你会听到关于他们工作的事，对吧？
It's just inevitable, right? The vocabulary becomes part of it. To me and my sister in particular, and my family more and more, as all that stuff gets into your life and you're doing that, we tend to now try and just work on the family stuff. Because that's just, to me,
这是不可避免的，对吧？这种词汇成了其中的一部分。对我尤其是我姐姐而言，以及我的家庭越来越多地，当所有这些东西进入你的生活并且你在做这件事时，我们现在往往倾向于只去处理家庭的事情。因为对我来说，
that's what I've grown to care about most. In the end, no matter what we all do and what we create, it all comes down to them being there, no matter what, right? They'll be there. Yeah. And do you have other siblings? Is it just you and Maggie?
那才是我渐渐最在乎的东西。到头来，不管我们做什么，不管我们创造了什么，归根结底都是因为他们一直在那里，无论发生什么，对吧？他们都会在那儿。对。你还有其他兄弟姐妹吗？只有你和玛吉吗？
I have a little half brother. I mean, he's a half brother. He's also little. My dad had another child. And so, yeah. But he's my half brother, he's my sister's half brother. And, but my sister and I, you know, grew up together just like.
我有一个同父异母的弟弟。我是说，他是同父异母的弟弟。他也还小。我父亲又生了一个孩子。所以，是的。但他是我同父异母的弟弟，也是我姐姐同父异母的弟弟。但是我和姐姐，你知道的，一起长大，就像……
And then what about, like, you and Mag, you've had, I'm assuming, a very positive experience with being in this business, and you've been able to transition from child actor into adult actor, and incredibly successful, both of you. Do you imagine that you would be supportive of your children going into this? Because I get this question all the time.
那还有什么，比如你和玛吉，我假设你们在这一行里有过非常积极的经历，你们能够从童星转型为成年演员，而且都取得了难以置信的成功。你会想象自己支持你的孩子进入这一行吗？因为我经常被问到这个问题。
How do you, I mean. My answer is always, yeah, I mean, I can't be hypocritical. I've had a great experience and it's been challenging, but it hasn't been detrimental or damaging. I would just make sure that I would condition my child or explain to my child what to look out for and what to not and what it is and what it isn't and just manage their expectations.
你该怎么，我是说。我的回答一直是，会的，我是说，我不能虚伪。我有着很棒的经历，虽然充满挑战，但它并不是有害的或破坏性的。我只会确保我会让我的孩子做好心理准备，或者向我的孩子解释要注意什么，什么不能做，什么是对的，什么不是，并且只是管理好他们的期望。
And then after that, let them make their own decision. But I mean, at 10 years old, which I was, and I think you were right around the same age, can you really assess all of the pitfalls such that you make a good decision? I don't know. I don't know. I mean, I think I would, my parents did a very smart thing, which is they were like,
在那之后，让他们自己做决定。但我是说，在10岁的时候，就像当年的我一样，我想你当时也差不多这个年纪，你真的能评估所有的陷阱从而做出一个明智的决定吗？我不知道。我不知道。我是说，我觉得我会，我父母做了一件非常明智的事情，那就是他们说：
you need to get an education. You know, they were very early on, they were like, I was like, I just want to do this thing, you know, and they were like, okay, cool, great. You can keep doing that, but you don't need to do it in like the deep end, right? Yeah, or in lieu of, yeah. Yeah, exactly. And, you know, socializing, you. And socializing was a huge thing. Go be amongst kids who are tough on you,
“你需要接受教育。”你知道的，他们很早就这样，我当时说：“我只想做这件事，”你知道的，他们说：“好吧，太酷了，很好。你可以继续做这件事，但你不需要一上来就直接跳进深水区去搞，对吧？”对，或者以牺牲其他为代价，对。对，没错。而且，你知道的，社交，你。社交是一件大事。去和那些对你严格的孩子们在一起，
you know what I mean, not just in an adult world. Yeah, if you can balance it, if you can handle it, go for it, yeah. Exactly. And then, yeah. No, go ahead. No, I just, to me, that's what I would do, I think. We can admit it's not a normal life in that way.
你知道我的意思吗，不只是生活在成年人的世界里。是的，如果你能平衡好，如果你能应付得来，那就去吧，对。没错。然后，对。不，你接着说。不，我只是觉得，对我来说，这就是我会做的。我们可以承认它在某种程度上不是一种正常的生活。
And so it's just important to get perspective. And I read that when you were a kid, you also used to volunteer at a homeless shelter and you celebrated your 13th birthday at one? Wow. Is that true? My mother's Jewish, my father's Christian. And so, they're not practicing very heavily,
所以保持客观视角很重要。我读到过，当你还是个孩子的时候，你还曾在无家可归者收容所做过志愿者，你甚至在那里庆祝了你的13岁生日？哇。这是真的吗？我母亲是犹太人，我父亲是基督徒。所以，他们并不是非常笃信宗教，
but they had a bit of a dilemma in my bar mitzvah moment, Kinsanera sort of situation. They didn't know really how to celebrate it. You had a combo bar mitzvah, Kinsanera? No, no. At a homeless shelter? So you got a deal on the venue. Basically.
但在我的成人礼（Bar Mitzvah）时刻——有点像成人礼（Quinceañera）那种情况——他们遇到了一个小小的两难境地。他们真的不知道该怎么庆祝。你办了一个合办的成人礼加十五岁生日派对？不，不。在无家可归者收容所？所以你在场地费上省了一大笔。基本上是这样。
And you... A real deal, a real deal. Everybody showed up too. Yeah, and so one of the things was they were like, my father was very big about passages, and that's what it was. They agreed that there was a passage of time and you were walking through this
而且你……真的省了一大笔，真的省了一大笔。所有人也都出席了。对，所以其中一件事是，他们觉得——我父亲非常看重人生阶段的过渡，事实也确实如此。他们一致认为生命中存在一个过渡期，你正走过这个
space and these are the qualities that, you know, they wanted me to understand and so they decided instead of something more formal, like we do all these different things and one of them was, yeah, we went to a homeless shelter on my birthday and fed the homeless, yeah. Wow. So it sounds like they started you out with just a great set of values, a decent, or a great guide in which to sort of be a decent person.
空间，而这些就是他们希望我理解的品质，所以他们决定不搞那么正式的形式，比如我们做了各种不同的事情，其中之一就是，是的，在我生日那天我们去了无家可归者收容所，给无家可归的人发食物，是的。哇。听起来他们一开始就为你树立了一套极好的价值观，一个让你成为一个正派之人的不错的——或者说极好的向导。
And you seem to have really held on to that. I mean, you know, you're just a really kind person and you've managed to acquire a great deal of success. Is it is it, you know, we're in such a permissive culture and atmosphere with what we do. Is it a constant, how much of a struggle is it for you to not take advantage of all the sort of latitude people like yourself are given, on set, off of set?
而且你似乎真的把这牢记在心了。我是说，你知道的，你真的是个非常善良的人，而且你设法取得了巨大的成功。是不是，你知道的，我们身处一个对我们所做的事情如此宽容的文化和氛围中。对你来说，为了不利用像你这样的人在片场、片场之外被赋予的各种特权，这是一种多大的挣扎？
Do you know what I mean? Because it's, I don't know, did they raise you well enough where it's not that much of a battle? I mean, I'm obsessed with my work. I love my work, right? And I dig into the characters that I do, do you know? And so that's sort of where I, like, to me, inside that learning, it has been, that's,
你知道我的意思吗？因为这，我不知道，他们把你抚养得很好，所以这其实不算是一场太激烈的斗争吗？我是说，我对我的工作着迷。我热爱我的工作，对吧？我深入钻研我所塑造的角色，你知道吗？所以这就是我，就像对我来说，在那种学习过程中，它一直是，
like, learning how to be an actor is a different thing, right, like, I don't think my parents were, they were not actors, right? Yeah, so it's a completely different Scenario teaching ought to be a good person not a good actor. Yeah, right. I mean they were sort of teaching I mean they were you know, they were like Learned great read great plays, you know, try and perform them so you can understand what we're life in the arts Yeah, kind of I mean for whatever I wanted really, whatever I felt they were down for. But I think like, you know, yeah,
就像，学习如何成为一个演员是另一回事，对吧，我觉得我父母不是，他们不是演员，对吧？对，所以这是一个完全不同的场景。教你如何成为一个好人，而不是一个好演员。对，没错。我是说他们某种程度上在教，我是说，他们，你知道的，他们就像是：多读伟大的剧作，你知道的，试着去表演它们，这样你就能理解艺术人生的意义。对，差不多，我是说不管我真正想要什么，无论我觉得他们会支持什么。但我认为，你知道的，
I think that's always the question, right? Like we grow up in it and when we grow up in it, it's a different thing. There are people who come into the business and they've experienced life and they experience success at a different age. And it's very interesting to watch people experience success at a different age. And it's very interesting to watch people experience success at different ages.
我觉得这永远是个问题，对吧？就像我们在这个行业里长大，当我们在这里长大时，情况就有所不同。有些人进入这个行业时已经经历过生活，他们在不同的年龄体验过成功。看着人们在不同的年龄体验成功是一件非常有趣的事。看着人们在不同的年龄体验成功是一件非常有趣的事。
And I was so grateful to experience it very early, but at the same time, it came with its own kind of growing up throughout the whole process. Right, yeah, like. I just watched City Slickers the other night. I swear to God, I just watched it. And I was like, is that Jake Gyllenhaal? You were like five?
我很感激能在很小的时候就经历这一切，但与此同时，这也伴随着在整个成长过程中逐渐成熟的代价。对，没错，就像。我前几天晚上刚看了《城市滑头》。我发誓，我刚看了。然后我想：那是杰克·吉伦哈尔吗？你当时才五岁？
How old were you in that? I was 11. And you can totally tell it's you. I never noticed that before. I was like, oh my God, Jake Gyllenhaal. Were you like Billy Crystal's son? I was Billy Crystal's son. No way, really.
你在那里面多大？我11岁。你完全能看出那是你。我以前从来没注意到过。当时我想：噢天哪，杰克·吉伦哈尔。你演的是比利·克rystal的儿子吗？我演的就是比利·克rystal的儿子。不会吧，真的吗。
And really Billy like, yeah, he like found me. And he was like, there's something about this kid. I mean, I have a poster that still says, he signed a poster for me for City Slickers poster and it says, thanks for letting me be in your first movie. Like he literally wrote that. No way. It was so cool.
而且比利真的是，对，他就像是发现了苗头。然后他说：“这孩子身上有种特质。”我是说，我有一张海报，上面写着，他为我签了一张《城市滑头》的海报，上面写着：“谢谢你让我参演你的第一部电影。”他真的是亲手写下了这个。不会吧。太酷了。
It's the best poster ever and he is the fucking best. Like I... He's such a nice man. Oh, such a nice man and like I worship him. Like I... It is very interesting. Who directed that? Was that... Ron Underwood. Oh, right. Yeah man and like I worship him. Like I, it's very interesting. Who directed that? Was that?
这是史上最棒的海报，而且他他妈的太棒了。就像我……他是个这么好的人。噢，真是个大好人，而且我崇拜他。就像我……这非常有意思。谁导的那个？是……朗·安德伍德。噢，对。是啊伙计，而且我崇拜他。就像我，这非常有意思。谁导的那个？是……
Ron Underwood. Oh right, yeah, yeah, yeah. Ron Underwood, who is Ron Underwood? I don't know that guy. You directed City Slickers. And then I love this, you were cast in Mighty Ducks but you couldn't take it, right? Or your parents didn't let you take it?
朗·安德伍德。噢对，对，对，对。朗·安德伍德，朗·安德伍德是谁？我不知道这家伙。你导了《城市滑头》。然后我喜欢这个，你本来被选中出演《野鸭变凤凰》，但你没演成，对吧？或者你父母不让你演？
You know like when people ask you guys like, oh, you got that part but you didn't do that part? Like and then you're like, why am I, someone else did it, It's theirs was is weird, but and that's a story that it's like We don't have them. I almost did the part that I'm never gonna do and you're and someone else did better than me So I don't why are we doing but I I yeah I was I auditioned for it and they let my parents would let me audition for things and so like without like being like Oh, sweet Jake. He wants to go audition for something, cool. And then I auditioned and I got it, pretty much.
你知道就像人们问你们这些演员：“哦，你拿到了那个角色，但你没演那个角色？”然后你会想：“为什么是我，别人演了，那是他们的……”这很诡异，但这是一个像这样的故事：我差点演了一个我永远不会去演的角色，然后有人比我演得更好，所以我不明白我们为什么要讨论这个。但我——是的，我去试镜了，他们允许我试镜各种东西，所以就像——没有那种“哦，可怜的杰克。他想去试镜点什么，挺酷的。”然后我试镜了，基本上就拿下了。
And they were like, oh shit. You have to go to school. And I was like, no, I wanna learn hockey. Yeah, by the way, Will, we have a lot to talk about that because you should talk to my parents. I wanted to learn how to play hockey. Oh, it's the best time of the day. Where's your hockey passion now?
然后他们就说：“噢操。你得去上学。”然后我说：“不，我想学冰球。”是的，顺便说一句，威尔，我们有很多关于这个的话题要聊，因为你应该去跟我父母聊聊。我想学打冰球。哦，那是那一整天里最棒的时光。你对冰球的热情现在还在吗？
Do you still have a hockey passion? No, I wasn't allowed it. I didn't do Mighty Ducks. But yeah, that was a thing. But a lot of the times, a lot of the role, like Jar had, God, you're so fucking good in that. And he's done so many great movies. Yeah, and all of these, last year.
你现在还有冰球情结吗？没，我不被允许。我没拍《野鸭变凤凰》。但是的，那是曾经的事。不过很多时候，很多角色，就像Jar有的，天哪，你在那里面演得太棒了。他演了那么多好电影。是的，所有这些，去年。
I just gotta say, I wish you had done fucking Mighty Ducks. Sorry, I just think of what could have been. I messed up, I messed up. But these roles in these big, huge movies that just seemed to me, I could never do the things you do, they just seemed like colossal undertakings as an actor. And the physicality that you take on is just remarkable. Like we were talking about at the beginning.
我得说，我真希望你他妈的演了《野鸭变凤凰》。抱歉，我只是在想本来可能会怎样。我搞砸了，我搞砸了。但这些在那些大制作电影里的角色，在我看来，我永远做不到你做的事，作为演员，这些对你来说就像是巨大的挑战。你所付出的体力劳动简直惊人。就像我们一开始在聊的那样。
What's, I love. You're brilliant, Sean. Thank you, I was waiting for that. We got it, he said it. But we do prefer a nice sitcom routine. You know, it's six hours a day. You and I have sung together, by the way. That's the thing. I know.
有什么，我喜欢。你太聪明了，肖恩。谢谢，我一直在等这句话。我们听到了，他说了。不过我们还是更喜欢可爱的情景喜剧日常。你知道的，一天工作六小时。顺便说一句，你和我一起唱过歌。就是那回事。我知道。
I mean. Really? Where'd you guys sing? Where? A whole new world. We sang at the Tony's, A Whole New World, yeah. No way. It was an arranged marriage, wasn't it? Do you have theater stories? If you have a theater story right now, Jake.
我是说。真的吗？你们在哪儿唱的？在哪儿？《崭新的世界》。我们在托尼奖上合唱了《崭新的世界》，是的。不会吧。那是包办婚姻，对吧？你们有什么剧场八卦吗？如果你现在有什么剧场八卦，杰克。
My favorite thing is medical stories and theater stories. Do you have to say, I listen to you guys, and I just want to say that I have a great losing a contact story. And I was like, what the fuck, that was my, when I'm on that, that was my fucking story. Sean, get Scotty in here. This is bullshit. Like, yeah, I thought, oh.
我最喜欢的是医疗八卦和剧场八卦。你要说，我听你们节目，我只想说我有一个极好的关于“隐形眼镜掉落”的故事。当时我想：他妈的，那是我当年的，那是我他妈的故事。肖恩，把斯科蒂叫进来。这太扯了。就像，是的，我想，哦。
That's my part. She stole my part, you know? We'll be right back. Hey, smart list listener. We get support from Helix. You didn't see that coming. We got the Helix mattresses over here at the Homestead and everybody sleeps better for it. And we've been doing it for a few years now. And I had some some sleeps that weren't great for a few years. And then the
那是我的部分。她偷了我的部分，你知道吗？我们马上回来。嘿，SmartLess的听众朋友。我们得到了Helix的大力支持。你没想到吧。我们在庄园这边也用上了Helix床垫，每个人因此都睡得更香了。而且我们已经用了好几年了。我以前有好几年都睡得不太好。然后
folks at Helix got involved with the show early. They were early in on the smart list party. And as a result of that, we took the test, all of us, and I got the mattress that was great for me. And I'll tell you about that in a second, but I can tell you this. I love the Helix mattresses. Everybody in the fam is resting their heads on them. The Helix lineup offers 20 unique mattresses including award-winning Luxe
Helix的朋友们很早就参与到了节目中。他们很早就加入了SmartLess的阵营。因此，我们所有人都做了测试，然后我拿到了最适合我的床垫。我一会儿会跟你细说，但我可以先告诉你这个：我爱死Helix床垫了。家里的每个人都在上面枕着头休息。Helix的产品线提供20种独特的床垫，包括屡获殊荣的Luxe
collection, the newly released Helix Elite collection. They got a mattress designed for big and tall sleepers and even a mattress made just for kids. And if your spin needs some extra TLC they got you. Because every Helix mattress has a hybrid design combining individually wrapped steel coils in the base with premium foam layers on top. It's a perfect combination of comfort and support. So I mentioned before, how will you know which Helix mattress works best for you and your body?
系列，以及最新发布的Helix Elite系列。他们有专为高大身材睡眠者设计的床垫，甚至还有专为儿童制造的床垫。如果你的脊椎需要额外的悉心呵护，他们也能满足你。因为每一款Helix床垫都采用混合设计，底部将独立袋装弹簧与顶部的优质泡沫层相结合。这是舒适与支撑的完美结合。我刚才提到了，你怎么知道哪款Helix床垫最适合你和你的身体呢？
Well, their team created a Helix sleep quiz to help you find your perfect mattress in under two minutes. You gotta have 2 minutes. You gotta have 2 minutes. And your mattress is shipped straight to your door free of charge. They're not gonna just throw it at your door. Trust me, they know what they're doing. They don't drive by in a truck and just launch the mattress at your house.
嗯，他们的团队创建了一个Helix睡眠测试，能帮你不到两分钟就找到最适合你的床垫。你肯定能抽出两分钟。你肯定能抽出两分钟。而且你的床垫会免费直接送到你家门口。他们可不会随便把它扔在你门口。相信我，他们很懂行。他们才不会开着卡车从门前驶过顺便把床垫朝你家一扔呢。
It's a whole system. Helix is offering 20% off all mattress orders and two free pillows for our listener. Go to helixsleep.com slash smartless and use code helixpartner20. This is their best offer yet and it won't last long. helixsleep.com slash smartless code helixpartner20. With Helix, better sleep starts now. Helix, better sleep starts now. Thank you to Nutrifol for supporting our show. A lot of us have a similar routine.
这是一整套流程。Helix为我们的听众提供所有床垫订单八折优惠以及两个免费枕头。请访问helixsleep.com/smartless并使用优惠码helixpartner20。这是他们迄今为止最好的优惠，而且不会持续太久。helixsleep.com/smartless优惠码helixpartner20。有了Helix，更好的睡眠从现在开始。Helix，更好的睡眠从现在开始。感谢Nutrafol对我们节目的支持。我们很多人都有着相似的日常：
We wake up tired. We probably scrolled too long again. And we grab something to eat as we rush out the door. It does the trick, but it isn't, it's not the nutritious breakfast that our bodies deserve. We get to work and the to-do list, oh wait, the phone rings. Your kid is sick and needs to be picked up early from school. And we just, it's like, it's insanity.
醒来时感到疲惫。我们可能又刷手机刷得太久了。然后匆忙出门时随便抓点东西吃。这倒也管用，但这绝对不是我们身体应得的营养早餐。我们到了公司，面对待办清单——等等，电话响了。你的孩子生病了，需要早点从学校接回来。而我们只能——这简直太疯狂了。
We all just have so much going on and we don't even think about all these things that could be impacting our hair health. Think about all these things that could be impacting our hair health. Your hair is never just about your hair and Nutrifol knows that. It could be your job, your deodorant, your hormones, or even your sushi order. It could be almost anything that has almost nothing to do with hair. That's why Nutrifol takes a whole body approach to hair health, addressing the problems inside to help hair grow on the outside, supporting your lifestyle, not just your
我们每个人都有太多事情要忙，甚至都不会去想所有这些可能会影响我们头发健康的事情。想想所有这些可能会影响我们头发健康的事情。你的头发从来不仅仅是头发那么简单，Nutrafol深知这一点。这可能是你的工作、你的除臭剂、你的荷尔蒙，甚至是你点的寿司外卖。几乎任何事都有可能，虽然这些事可能跟头发毫无关系。这就是为什么Nutrafol采用全身体的方法来关爱头发健康，从内部解决问题以帮助头发在外部生长，支持你的生活方式，而不仅仅是你的
hair style. With Nutri-Fol, building a hair growth routine is simple. Purchase online, no prescription or doctor's visits required, free shipping and automated deliveries ensure you'll never miss a day and see results in three to six months. Address your root causes of hair thinning with Nutrifol. For a limited time, Nutrifol is offering our listener $10 off your first month's subscription and free shipping when you go to Nutrifol.com and enter the promo code SMARTLESS. Neutrophol.com, spelled N-U-T-R-A-F-O-L.com. Promo code SMARTLESS. That's Neutrophol.com.
发型。有了Nutrifol，建立头发生长日常非常简单。在线购买，无需处方或看医生，免费送货和自动配送确保你不会错过任何一天，并在三到六个月内看到效果。用Nutrifol解决头发变薄的根本原因。限时特惠，Nutrifol为我们的听众提供首月订阅立减10美元并免运费的优惠，只需访问Nutrifol.com并输入促销码SMARTLESS。Nutrafol.com，拼写是N-U-T-R-A-F-O-L.com。促销码是SMARTLESS。网址是Nutrifol.com。
Promo code SMARTLESS. SMARTLESS listener, let me tell you about the Defender 110. For those who embrace the impossible, the Defender 110 is up for the adventure. This iconic vehicle's exterior and interior has been redefined with a thoroughly modern design. The Defender's capability is legendary whether you're facing off-road challenges or harsh weather conditions. You can rely on their innovative camera technologies to deliver unobstructed views and effortless
促销码SMARTLESS。SmartLess的听众朋友，让我跟你们聊聊卫士110（Defender 110）。对于那些拥抱不可能的人来说，卫士110随时准备好迎接冒险。这款标志性车辆的外观和内饰已经通过彻底现代的设计进行了重新定义。无论你面对的是越野挑战还是恶劣天气条件，卫士的性能都是传奇级别的。你可以信赖他们创新的摄像头技术，以提供清晰无阻的视野和轻松的
maneuvering. Plus, their powerful innovations like the intuitive driver display and award-winning infotainment system make sure you stay connected. I always imagine myself driving in one, pulling up to some event, and people going, hey, look at that guy, look at that car.
操控体验。此外，他们强大的创新功能，如直观的驾驶员显示屏和屡获殊荣的信息娱乐系统，能确保你始终保持连线。我总是想象自己开着这样一辆车，驶向某个活动现场，然后人们说：“嘿，看那个家伙，看那辆车。”
He sure looks sleek, he sure looks like he knows what he's doing. Well, my response to that would be like, the car knows what they're doing, I don't. Ready for a wide range of adventures? The Defender family features the two-door Defender 90, the Defender 110, and the Defender 130, which seats up to eight.
“他看起来真时髦，看起来对一切都胸有成竹。”好吧，我对这番话的反应会是：“车知道自己在干嘛，我可不知道。”准备好迎接各种冒险了吗？卫士家族包括双门卫士90（Defender 90）、卫士110（Defender 110）以及最多可容纳八座的卫士130（Defender 130）。
Learn more at LandRoverUSA.com forward slash Defender. SmartList is brought to you in part by Airbnb. Scotty and I had a couple friends in recently, actually more than two, and they rented an Airbnb because we didn't have the space for them. And we went over there and it was like beautiful. It was gorgeous. And I was like, wow, I can't believe people rent their places out like this. And they do because it's such a good idea. I don't know, maybe you've stayed in an Airbnb before and thought to yourself, this actually seems pretty doable. Maybe my place could
了解更多信息请访问LandRoverUSA.com正斜杠Defender。SmartLess部分内容由Airbnb为您呈现。斯科蒂和我最近接待了几位朋友，实际上不止两位，他们租了一间Airbnb，因为我们没有足够的空间接待他们。我们过去看了看，简直太漂亮了。美极了。当时我想：“哇，我真不敢相信人们会把自己的地方这样出租出去。”他们确实这么做了，因为这真的是个好主意。我不知道，也许你以前也住过Airbnb，然后心想：这其实挺可行的嘛。也许我的地方也可以
be an Airbnb. It could be as simple as starting with a spare room or your whole place when you're away. You could be sitting on an Airbnb and not even know it. Maybe you're planning a getaway this year. While you're away, you could Airbnb your home and make some extra money toward the trip. Your home might be worth more than you think.
成为一间Airbnb。这可以很简单，从出租一间空房开始，或者在你外出时整套出租你的房子。你可能正坐拥一间Airbnb却浑然不知。也许你今年正在计划一次度假。当你外出时，你可以把你的房子挂在Airbnb上，为这次旅行赚取一些额外的零花钱。你的家可能比你想象的更值钱。
Find out how much at airbnb.ca slash host. And now back to the show. So there you are, you're on stage. What happened? I'm on stage and so I did this show with Ruth Wilson called Constellations, which is this amazing show, two-hander, it's 75 scenes in 90 minutes. Basically like, and the changes of scenes, it's about a couple, and it's a bit like sliding doors-ish,
访问airbnb.ca/host了解具体价值。现在回到我们的节目。所以你就站在那儿，你在舞台上。发生了什么？我在舞台上，我跟露丝·威尔逊（Ruth Wilson）演了一部名为《星座》（Constellations）的剧，这是一部超级棒的双人剧，90分钟里有75场戏。基本上就像，场景的转换，讲的是一对情侣的故事，有点像是电影《滑动门》（Sliding Doors）那种感觉，
but it's about, there are basically five scenes that happen over a couple's relationship, and within the five scenes, there are like eight scenes of the different potential things that could happen, right? So first they meet, and then one of them's not into the other and the other one is, and then boom, the lights change, and then the other one who wasn't into the other is into the other and the other one is and then boom the lights change And then the other one who wasn't into the other is into the other, you know So it switches then they're both into each into each other the next one
但它是关于，基本上有五场戏发生在一对情侣的关系中，在这五场戏中，大约有八场不同的潜在可能发生的事情，对吧？所以首先他们相遇，然后其中一个人对另一个人没感觉，而另一个人有感觉，然后——轰，灯光变了，接着之前没感觉的那个人对另一个人有感觉了，而另一个——然后——轰，灯光变了。接着之前没感觉的那个人对另一个人有感觉了，你知道的，所以角色互换了，接下来他们俩对彼此都有感觉了
Then neither of them are into each other and then it moves forward, right? And so subsequently actually there gets to him asking her to marry him and I had in tech, you know, like... The final rehearsals, right? The final rehearsals. For Tracy, that's the final rehearsals. I had said basically like,
然后他们俩对彼此都没感觉了，接着剧情继续推进，对吧？随之而来的实际发展是，剧情进展到他向她求婚。而我在彩排时，你知道的……最后的彩排，对吧？对崔西来说，那是最后的彩排。我当时基本上说过，
okay, we had one prop in the whole show. It was just two people on stage. We never left this platform, right? It was 90 minutes, never left. There was one prop, and the prop was a ring in my pocket that I kept, and you had to prep all stuff. And I said to the stage manager, I said, can I just put some contact lenses under the stage in the back because I just I really am
好吧，整部戏里我们只有一个道具。舞台上只有两个人。我们从头到尾没离开过这个平台，对吧？整整90分钟，从头到尾没离开。只有一个道具，那个道具就是藏在我口袋里的一枚戒指，你得把所有东西都准备好。我对舞台经理说，我说：“我能不能在舞台后面的台阶底下放一些隐形眼镜，因为我真的是——”
legal I'm legally blind without contact lens like I no no I am legally blind like I I cannot I can't like function. Your contacts in right now? No I you get but you guys look great. I would be deeply offended if we were making love right now and I found out you didn't have your contacts in. You didn't even bother. You didn't even bother bringing his fucking contact lenses for us. So I just like, you know, actually at the same time, I like, I had gotten into a little thing with with Ruth early on because my brother-in-law who's an amazing actor by the way he yeah he came to see me in
法定盲人，如果没有隐形眼镜我是法定盲人，不不不，我是法定盲人，我——我简直无法——我无法正常生活。你现在戴着隐形眼镜吗？没有，你——但你们看起来状态不错。如果我们在亲热的时候我发现你没戴隐形眼镜，我会深受冒犯的。你甚至懒得。你甚至懒得为我们带上你他妈的隐形眼镜。所以我只是，你知道的，其实与此同时，我喜欢——我早期跟露丝闹过一点小别扭，因为我姐夫——顺便说一句，他是个了不起的演员——他，是的，
previews and he gave me notes and he gave me two notes one note was he was like still there's power and stillness because I think I was moving around a lot trying to get a lot of attention and the next note was don't let her upstage you yeah she kept walking upstage huh I mean, I think he actually meant like, she's just a better actor than you, so just try harder and figure it out because she is a better actor than me. I learned that over the course of the run.
他来看我预演，他给我提了意见。他给了我两个意见：一个意见是“静止中自有力量”，因为我觉得我当时动来动去的，试图吸引很多注意；第二个意见是“别让她抢了你的风头”。对，她一直在往舞台深处走，哼。我是说，我觉得他实际上意思是：“她就是个比你更好的演员，所以你得更努力去搞定它，因为她确实比我演技更好。”我在巡演的过程中意识到了这一点。
Because Tracy, if an actor walks upstage, it forces you to turn your back to the audience to talk to that person, and now the audience can't see your face, they can only see the person on stage. Right. And she does, she's just magical. Like she's just the type of actor that like,
因为崔西，如果一个演员往舞台深处走，就会逼得你必须把后背转向观众去跟那个人说话，这样观众就看不到你的脸了，只能看到舞台深处的那个人。对。而且她就是这样，她简直有种魔力。她就是那种演员，就像——
I'd always talk about this like when Saturday nights, you know, it's like the energy is so much more intense. And Saturday nights, like she would ride that energy like a wave and I'd be like, oh, it's so intense. And she'd be like, see ya. You know, and they'd be like, the roof is incredible. So he was like, just don't, try not to let her do that. Like try and surf, don't be afraid.
我总是提到这一点，就像周六晚上的演出，你知道的，那种能量要强烈得多。到了周六晚上，她会像驾驭波浪一样驾驭那种能量，而我就会想：“噢，这太强烈了。”她就会说：“拜啦。”你知道的，然后大家会说：“露丝太不可思议了。”所以他当时的意思是：“别，尽量别让她那么干。试着去冲浪，别害怕。”
Stay with her. Yeah. And so we had gotten into a thing where like, I was like, I was like, I feel like you're upstaging me. She was like, I'm not, I'm just like, the actor bullshit. She's like, I'm not, what are you talking about? And I'm like, can we just try and stay on the same line?
跟上她的节奏。是的。所以我们当时闹得有点僵，我当时就说：“我觉得你在抢我的戏。”她说：“我没有，我只是——”这就是演员那些废话。她说：“我没有，你在说什么呢？”我说：“我们能不能尽量保持在同一条线上？”
Like, you know, like, because this is about us, you know? And it was like, I'm not, what are you talking about? And I'm like, can we just try and stay on the same line? Like, you know, like, cause this is about us, you know? And it was like, hold on. So anyway, the light changes, by the way, these big pops in the show. So you have about like a second and a quarter to kind of change, right? And at the same time that I, in the, it's very hard to explain because I would put my hand
就像，你知道的，因为这是关于我们俩的事，你知道吗？然后就变成：“我没有，你在说什么呢？”我说：“我们能不能尽量保持在同一条线上？”就像，你知道的，因为这是关于我们俩的事，你知道吗？然后就变成：等等。不管怎样，灯光变了，顺便说一句，剧里这些光效变化非常大。所以你大概只有一又四分分之一秒的时间来做转换，对吧？与此同时，在我——在那个场景里，这很难解释，因为我会在那场准备向她
in my pocket in the scene before I'm supposed to ask her To marry me because I pull out the ring and no one's seen a prop and so they go Oh, how do you get that ring? Right? Right. I put my hands in my pockets and the ring was not in my pockets So I was like, it's the only prop by the way in tech they were I was like, what if we okay I have contact lenses up there, but what if like I don't have the problem. They're like dude, is it Broadway? We have a prop master usually deals with a thousand props. He has one prop. Okay, so don't worry.
求婚的戏之前把手插进口袋里，因为我要掏出戒指，而之前没有人看到过这个道具，所以他们会想：“哦，这戒指是哪来的？”对吧？对吧？我把手伸进口袋里，结果口袋里根本没有戒指。所以我当时想：这是全剧唯一的道具，顺便说一句，在彩排时他们还在说——我当时说：“如果我们在上面放隐形眼镜呢？但如果没有道具怎么办？”他们说：“老兄，这是百老汇好吗？我们通常有道具主管要应付一千个道具。他只有一个道具。好吧，所以不用担心。”
You're gonna have your prop. Okay, don't worry. I was like, I know, but if, they're like, just, and I was like, can I just please, they're like, crazy, sure. And they put it there. So I rub my eye, contact lens falls out in the scene. I put my hand into my pocket, I can't find the fucking ring. And I'm like, oh my God, I can't see anything.
你会拿到道具的。好吧，别担心。我当时想，我懂，但如果……他们就说，只要……然后我说，我能拜托……他们就像疯了一样，当然。然后他们把它放在那。所以我揉了揉眼睛，隐形眼镜在戏里掉了出来。我把手伸进口袋，找不到那该死的戒指。我说，天哪，我什么都看不见了。
And then Ruth, and then I start to move upstage, because I remember there's a contact lens in there, and the ring is over there. And Ruth starts looking at me like, oh you motherfucker, I know what you're doing. You're going up stage. You asshole. I was like, I can't see anything. Like inside of trying to communicate. And she thinks you're just winking at her, Constantine.
然后露丝，接着我开始往舞台深处走，因为我记得那里有一枚隐形眼镜，而戒指在那边。露丝开始看着我，眼神仿佛在说，你个混蛋，我知道你在干嘛。你要去舞台深处。你个混蛋。我当时想，我什么都看不见了。就像是在试图沟通。而她以为你只是在向她抛媚眼，康斯坦丁。
Oh I know what's up. And then as soon as I like, boom, lights pop, I run over, grab the contact lenses, grab the thing, and I put the contact lens in my eye, because I can do it, because I've been putting contact lenses in my eye since I was a kid, like really, really young. And then she was like, oh, oh my God, like she realized in the moment.
哦，我知道怎么回事。然后一旦我像这样，轰，灯光亮起，我跑过去，抓起隐形眼镜，抓起那个东西，然后我把隐形眼镜戴回眼睛里，因为我做得到，我从小就开始戴隐形眼镜了，非常非常小的时候。然后她就说，噢，天哪，她在那一刻反应过来了。
Yeah, that wasn't, yeah. Yeah, that's funny, I used to do this thing, and I promise, I promise, is that there's this guy, his name's, thank you so much. By the way, beautiful. Incredible. His name's Ryan, and we would give each other horrible, horrible shit, like right before
对，那不是……对。对，真搞笑，我以前常干这事，我发誓，我发誓，就是有个家伙，他叫……非常感谢。顺便说一句，太美妙了。不可思议。他叫瑞安，我们会在上台前互相开一些超级无聊、超级恶劣的玩笑，就像
we'd end of the stage. It's kind of like the three of us do, just like scathing, right? And he goes, I'm actually dead serious before, tonight can you make sure that during this one dance sequence, because you're blocking, you're just blocking me, just every so I go, Ryan, I'm going to stop you. I never look behind me on stage.
我们快上台的时候。有点像我们三个干的那种，就是尖酸刻薄的玩笑，对吧？然后他说，我今晚之前是认真的，今晚你能不能确保在某个舞蹈段落中，因为你的走位，你正好挡住我，就在我每次——我说，瑞安，我要打断你。我在舞台上从不往后看。
What a sweetheart. Now, Jake, if you're not acting, if you're not exercising, being physical, what else are you doing to fill your time? What is, you don't have any, like are you a reader? Are you a TV watcher? Are you a painter? Do you love to knit? Speaking of knitting, I'm gonna get my mom in here
真是个大甜心。话说回来，杰克，如果你不演戏，如果不锻炼、不做体力活动，你还用什么来打发时间？有什么……你没有什么……你是个爱看书的人吗？你是电视迷吗？你是画家吗？你喜欢织毛衣吗？说到织毛衣，我一会儿要把我妈叫进来，
in a second, cause she's mad that you guys still haven't sent her a picture of the fucking sweaters. I did, just tell her to check a junk file? I collect shoe horns actually You have no odd You have no odd hobby or... I cook a lot. I cook a lot. I cook major. Yeah, I want to talk about cooking. I didn't know you cook. Yeah, yeah, yeah. But you're not cooking fatty shit.
因为她很生气的你们到现在还没给她发那件该死的毛衣的照片。我发了，叫她查一下垃圾邮件箱不就行了？其实我收集鞋拔子。你没有什么奇怪的……你没有什么奇怪的爱好或者……我经常做饭。我经常做饭。我做得很专业。对，我想聊聊做饭。我都不知道你会做饭。对，对，对。但你做的不是那种油腻的垃圾食品吧。
You're good at cooking like veggie stuff or macrobiotic or something. I mean... I cook everything. I love to cook. I love to shop for food. So then you eat what you want, you just make sure that you exercise a lot. No, I mean, no. I've actually, you know, I've tried all different things. I'm down with intermittent fasting. I really like that as an idea,
你擅长做素食或者生机饮食之类的东西吧。我是说……我什么都做。我喜欢做饭。我喜欢买菜。然后你想吃什么就吃什么，只要确保自己经常锻炼就行。不，我是说，没有。我其实，你知道的，我尝试过各种不同的方法。我挺赞成间歇性断食的。我真的很喜欢这个概念，
because I tend to go like, I'm gonna just overeat. You know, so instead I just go like, we're just not gonna eat today for a while. It's all or nothing. Are you sweet tooth or salty? What's your? Ultimately, I think I'm a sweet tooth, yeah. I just like, I'm a cake.
因为我往往会想，我今天就要暴饮暴食。你知道的，所以反过来我就会想，我们今天干脆有一段时间不吃东西。要么全盘接受，要么彻底拉倒。你是喜欢吃甜的还是咸的？你的口味是怎样的？归根结底，我觉得我更喜欢甜食，对。我就是喜欢，我超爱蛋糕。
I like cake. I have massive sweet tooth. I love cake. I got it. I'm a pie guy. Do you guys know Yosia Refi, by the way? No. Her cookbooks.
我喜欢蛋糕。我特别爱吃甜食。我超爱蛋糕。我懂了。我是个派控。顺便问一下，你们知道约西亚·雷菲（Yotam Ottolenghi）吗？不知道。她的食谱。
Uh-uh. She has this book called, I'm like, this is a shameless plug on her book, but it is incredible. It's called Snacking Cakes. Snacking Cakes. Yeah, and there's also this lemon cake that she makes that has pieces, the recipe has pieces of the lemon in it.
呃，没有。她有本书叫——我觉得这简直是在给她打厚脸皮的广告，但它真的不可思议。书名叫《零食蛋糕》（Snacking Cakes）。《零食蛋糕》。对，她还做过一种柠檬蛋糕，里面有切碎的柠檬，食谱里就包含柠檬的小碎块。
So it's like, I don't know if you like a lemon cake. Love. I do. I don't wanna eat a piece of lemon though. No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. Like you chop, it's small, it's in little pieces, but you get like this sort of burst of citrus, so to speak. And like you really do know it's like, I'm a sucker for glazes like that.
所以就像是——我不知道你喜不喜欢柠檬蛋糕。超爱。我喜欢。不过我可不想吃到一整块柠檬。不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不。就像你切碎它，它很小，是一小块一小块的，但你会尝到那种柑橘味爆开的感觉，可以说是这样。而且你真的能感觉到，我就是对这种糖霜毫无抵抗力。
Oh yeah, I like that. Would you be into that, Sean? You think you might be into a cake? I love like a lemon pound cake. Garbage can. No, I love that though. I got an ice cream maker for Christmas. Huh.
哦对，我喜欢那个。肖恩，你会喜欢那个吗？你觉得你会喜欢蛋糕吗？我超爱那种柠檬磅蛋糕。垃圾桶。不，不过我超喜欢。我圣诞节收到了一台冰淇淋机。哈。
I like... Well, you want to cut out the middleman. He was too much with the fucking sire to drive him to the ice cream maker for Christmas. I like pastry. Well, he wanted to cut out the middle man. It was too much with the fucking sire to drive him to the ice cream shop. Get out of the store, just fucking make it here. I'd rather just cry and make it while I cry, you know? Like I just. By this time next year, he's gonna figure out
我喜欢……好吧，你想省去中间商。他用那个该死的雪橇载他去买冰淇淋机，这在圣诞节时太夸张了。我喜欢糕点。好吧，他是想省去中间商。用那个该死的雪橇载他去冰淇淋店实在是太夸张了。别去店里了，直接在这儿做吧。我宁愿边哭边做，你知道吗？就像我……明年这个时候，他肯定连
how to make ice cream in his mouth. Yeah. Okay. Okay, wait. Wait a minute, I wanna talk about Roadhouse, because it comes out March 21st. I'm primed, which is really exciting. Wait, were you nervous to make such a classic film,
怎么在嘴里做冰淇淋都琢磨出来了。好吧。好吧，等等。等一下，我想聊聊《路边饭店》（Road House），因为这部电影3月21日上映。我都准备好了，这真的很让人兴奋。等等，翻拍这样一部经典电影，你当时会紧张吗？
because, you know, Patrick Swayze, we all love Patrick Swayze, I'm sure you're gonna kill it, but were you nervous? I mean, I knew Patrick Swayze was in Donnie Darko, this film that I did. Oh, that's right, that's right. Oh, you little fuck. That's right.
因为，你知道的，帕特里克·斯威兹，我们所有人都爱帕特里克·斯威兹，我确信你一定会大获成功，但你当时紧张吗？我是说，我知道帕特里克·斯威兹演过《死亡幻觉》（Donnie Darko），我拍过的那部电影。哦，对哦，对哦。哦，你这个小坏蛋。没错。
Yeah, he's like, no. Yeah, Donnie Darko. Can I also just say, before you get, that's right. Oh, you little fuck. That's right. He's like. Johnny Darko. Yeah, Johnny Darko. Can I also just say before you get, Nightcrawler, I don't know why, it just occurred to me, I just remembered how much I fucking loved that movie, dude. All your movies are great. It was so great, it was such a good movie, so good. Didn't Bob Elswit shoot that?
对，他才不。对，《死亡幻觉》。顺便问一下，在你开始之前，没错。哦，你这个小坏蛋。没错。他就像。乔尼·达科（Johnny Darko）。对，乔尼·达科。我能顺便说一下吗，在你开始之前，还有《夜行者》（Nightcrawler），我不知道为什么，我刚刚突然想起来，我突然记起我有多他妈喜欢那部电影了，老兄。你所有的电影都很棒。太棒了，真是一部好电影，好极了。那部电影不是鲍勃·艾斯威特（Robert Elswit）掌镜的吗？
He did, yeah. He's a buddy of yours. The one time I've ever been in a room with him was at your house at a birthday party that you had, and I saw him walking around, I was like, what the fuck is going on? He's a cinematographer, everybody, and he's a god. That movie's a fucking masterpiece.
是的，没错。他是你的好朋友。我和他共处一室只有过一次，那是在你家办的一个生日派对上，我看到他在那儿走来走去，我当时想，这他妈是怎么回事？大家注意，他是摄影师，而且他是神。那部电影简直是一部他妈的杰作。
So anyway, so you're doing- I love that movie too, but Road House. So you worked with Swayze in Dirty Darko. He was just the sweetest, most generous, kindest man. I was like, when we worked together, and Point Break was a movie that I watched, maybe I've watched that movie more than any movie I've ever watched, if I'm honest. Because I reacted so many hours from like nine years old to like, admittedly 43. I just love that movie.
所以无论如何，你在拍——我也很喜欢那部电影，但是《路边饭店》。所以你在《死亡幻觉》里和斯威兹合作过。他简直是世界上最甜美、最大方、最善良的人。我当时想，当我们一起合作时，《惊爆点》（Point Break）是我看过的电影中，说实话，我看的次数可能比我看过的任何一部电影都要多。因为我从九岁到——老实说，43岁，花了那么多小时反复重温。我就是超爱那部电影。
And I love a lot of his movies and and Roadhouse I remember these faint memories of the poster and I don't know where I remember seeing it And then I also remember watching clips of it or it was on TV and being like what is this like I like it Is it's like ingrained in my unconscious this this movie and so like Doug Lyman who's a good friend of mine We've been friends for 20 years. Brilliant, right, director. Amazing. Brilliant. And he was like, we've been trying to find a movie for a long time to do together.
我也很喜欢他的很多电影，对于《路边饭店》，我还依稀记得海报的模糊记忆，我不知道是在哪里看到过它的。然后我还记得看过它的片段，或者是在电视上看到过，当时就在想，这是什么？我挺喜欢的。这部电影简直深深地烙印在我的潜意识里了。所以，像道格·里曼（Doug Lyman），他是我的好朋友，我们已经认识20年了。才华横溢的导演。太棒了。才华横溢。他当时就说，我们一直想找一部电影一起合作很久了。
And he was like, we were talking one night, because we were talking about one other movie that he had sent me, we were talking about it, and he was like, you know, I do have this other idea. They just sent me this script of Roadhouse. It's like a re-imagining of it. And I was like, I'm fucking in. I literally was, he said, and I like,
然后他说，有一天晚上我们聊天时，因为我们当时在聊他发给我的另一部电影，我们在讨论那个，然后他就说，你知道吗，我其实还有另一个想法。他们刚刚把《路边饭店》的剧本发给我。有点像是它的重新构想版。我当时就说，我他妈接了。我literally就，他说，然后我——
it was like the, whoever saw those clips, whoever, it just came out of me. Like, I'm in. Wow. And so. I mean, you filmed an actual fight with a live audience? I went to the UFC to film, yeah, we went to the UFC and I filmed in the Octagon.
就像是，不管是谁看到那些片段，不管是谁，那句话直接脱口而出。就像，我接了。哇。所以。我是说，你是在有现场观众的情况下实拍了一场打斗戏？我去UFC（终极格斗冠军赛）现场拍摄了，对，我们去了UFC，我在八角笼里拍的。
What? It was. Yeah? It was so fun. It was so incredible. It was incredible. They let us film there. The UFC was amazing. It was nuts. I was like high from it for four days after. Would you say that you got into the best sort of cardiovascular shape you've ever been in
什么？是的。真的吗？太好玩了。太不可思议了。简直难以置信。他们让我们在那里拍。UFC太棒了。太疯狂了。拍完后我兴奋了整整四天。你会说，通过缠斗，你达到了你一生中最好的心血管体能状态吗？
through grappling? Because like, I mean, you think you're in shape until you start wrestling with someone. Like, you're in shape until you start wrestling with someone. the best sort of cardiovascular shape you've ever been in through grappling, because like, I mean, you think you're in shape until you start wrestling with someone. Like, it's crazy how tired you get, right? Try wrestling with Conor McGregor. I was just gonna say, I can't believe,
因为，我的意思是，在你开始和别人摔跤之前，你觉得自己体能很好。就像，在你开始和别人摔跤之前，你觉得自己体能很好。通过缠斗，你达到了你一生中最好的心血管体能状态吗？因为，我的意思是，在你开始和别人摔跤之前，你觉得自己体能很好。就像，你累得有多快这简直太疯狂了，对吧？去和康纳·麦格雷戈（Conor McGregor）摔跤试试。我正要说呢，我简直不敢相信，
is this his first acting gig? Yeah, it is. Yeah, it's his first act. I mean, it depends on how much you consider the performance pre-fight, but yes, this is his first act gig professionally. Wow, that's pretty wild. How was that process shooting in front of those crowds? I gotta say, mixed martial arts makes me nervous sometimes.
这是他的第一部表演作品吗？对，是的。对，这是他的第一部表演作品。我是说，这取决于你在多大程度上把赛前的表现也算作表演，不过是的，这是他职业生涯的第一部表演作品。哇，这太疯狂了。在那些观众面前拍摄的过程是怎样的？我得说，综合格斗有时确实让我感到紧张。
Not just the crowds, it's a little... Yeah, they want blood. It's very dangerous. It's like the Colosseum back in the old days. Yeah, it's like a little bit of Colosseum, but it always makes me nervous because there's bloodlust, right? People are out there in a really fucking heart-wrenching.
不仅仅是观众，有点……对，他们渴望看到血腥。这非常危险。就像过去的罗马斗兽场一样。对，有点像古罗马斗兽场，但这总是让我感到紧张，因为有一种嗜血的感觉，对吧？人们去那里真的非常揪心。
You get on the canvas, and we were right before the main cards. One of the prelims? Yeah, so it was like post-prelims, it was pre-pay-per-view. We were told we were gonna either like 45 seconds or seven minutes. We didn't know. Because depending on how the earlier fights went, if they went all the way, if they finished in the first 30 seconds, like that would accumulate our time, right?
你上了擂台，我们就在主赛之前。其中一场副赛？对，所以就像副赛之后，按次付费直播之前。我们被告知我们要么打45秒，要么打七分钟。我们不知道。因为这取决于早前的比赛进展如何，如果它们打满了整场，如果在前30秒就结束了，那就会挤压我们的时间，对吧？
So they wouldn't guarantee us anything. So, but by the time we got there, there had been some really, really intense fights. And I walked up onto the canvas and there was just so much blood on the mat. Are you kidding me? No, there's just blood all over the canvas. They don't clean it? No, it's canvas. Did you, could you wear slippers during the...
所以他们什么都不保证。但是，当我们到达那里的时候，已经有了一些非常非常激烈的比赛。我走上擂台，垫子上真的有太多的血。你在开玩笑吗？没有，整个擂台到处都是血。他们不清理吗？不，那是垫子。你，你在……的时候能穿拖鞋吗？
Oh yeah, don't worry. I wore... Fuckin' shit. Feet condoms. There we go. No, I, it's really... It's actually... Faehman, fuck it.
哦对，别担心。我穿了……他妈的。脚部安全套。这就对了。不，我，这真的……实际上……费曼，去他的。
Faehman's gonna go wash his hands just to show you that it's dirty. One of the things they don't tell you about, Jason, is that, you know, in grappling in particular, and mixed martial arts, you know, staff is like a big thing. And because like, there's just everybody's grappling on these mats, right? And actually when we were shooting, when we were shooting Roadhouse, I got staff, yeah, we were shooting and my arm like blew up.
费曼要去洗手，只是为了让你看看它有多脏。杰森，有一件事他们没有告诉你，你知道的，特别是在缠斗和综合格斗中，你知道的，葡萄球菌感染是一件大事。因为每个人都在这些垫子上缠斗，对吧？其实我们在拍戏的时候，我们在拍《路边饭店》时，我感染了葡萄球菌，对，我们在拍戏，我的手臂肿了起来。
And I was like, what is this? I didn't know what it was. And I, here we go, Sean, here's a medical story. Yeah, I love it. And I thought it was because I, here we go, Sean, here's a medical story. Yeah, I love it. And I thought it was because this big, there's a big final fight between me and Conor McGregor in it. And Conor is, I mean, he's amazing.
然后我在想，这是什么？我不知道那是什么。然后，来吧，肖恩，这里有个医疗故事。对，我喜欢。我以为是因为，来吧，肖恩，这里有个医疗故事。对，我喜欢。我以为是因为这个盛大的，我和康纳·麦格雷戈之间有一场很大的最终大战。康纳他，我的意思是，他太棒了。
And he coached me through a lot of our fights, right? He was like, he came in, he was like, I'm a white belt in this movie world, this acting world, I'm here to learn from you. I was like, it was such humility. I said, well, I'm obviously less than a white belt in your world, so you tell me what you need me to do. Yeah, no, every time we'd have to say to Connor,
他指导了我很多打斗戏，对吧？他走过来，就像是，在这个电影世界、这个表演世界里，我是一个白带，我是来向你学习的。我说，这太谦逊了。我说，我显然连你那里的白带都不如，所以你告诉我需要我做什么。对，不，每次我们都得对康纳说，
they'd be like, we're rolling, okay, marker, and then it'd be like, I'd have to say, remember, even two months into shooting, remember, don't hit me in the face, remember that. And he'd be like, oh yeah, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right. It was that every time before every take. Yeah. Moneymaker, moneymaker.
他们会说，我们开始拍摄了，好，打板，然后就变成，我得说，记住，甚至在开拍两个月后，记住，不要打我的脸，记住这一点。他就会说，哦，对，对，对，对，对，对，对，对，对。每次开拍前都是这样。摇钱树，摇钱树。
Was the crowd aware that you guys were shooting a movie and were told to like just kind of cheer this fight on like you would? No, not all of them because some people were like well what they started to do is they picked up on us filming and then they realized that there was like kind of a good guy and a bad guy in the fight. And then they started cheering when like I would throw a punch and they'd be like, they'd be like, yeah! And then it was like 15,000 people cheering for this thing.
观众知道你们在拍电影，并被告知就像平时那样为这场比赛欢呼吗？不，并非所有人，因为有些人是这样的，嗯，他们开始注意到我们在拍摄，然后他们意识到比赛中似乎有一个好人和一个坏人。然后当我会出拳时，他们就开始欢呼，他们会说，他们会说，耶！然后就有1万5千人为这个欢呼。
And that was accurate for the story? Like you were the good guy? They had no idea, yeah. They had no idea. Wow. Where was it? We were in Vegas. It was 285.
这符合故事情节吗？就像你是好人？他们完全不知道，对。他们完全不知道。哇。在哪里？我们在拉斯维加斯。那是第285期。
I was supposed to do 283, and then I got, the night before, got COVID, and we had the whole crew ready to go. And so we had to wait. What's 285? It's the number. Number of fights. Oh, wow.
我本该参加第283期，然后我，在前一天晚上，得了新冠，而我们的整个剧组都准备好了。所以我们不得不等待。什么是285？这是期数。比赛的场次。哦，哇。
Wow. And did you get hurt at all? During the filming? Yeah. The staff infection. All the time. Well, yeah, I guess. The staff infection in the end,
哇。你受伤了吗？在拍摄期间？对。葡萄球菌感染。一直都是。好吧，对，我猜。最后的葡萄球菌感染，
I didn't know it was a staff infection, and I woke up and I was like, this, my elbow feels weird. I thought it was just because I had grabbed Connor like 30 times in this one moment. And I thought, oh, he was just throwing this arm down on me and I was grabbing it so hard that I thought, it just hurt my elbow.
我不知道那是葡萄球菌感染，我醒来后觉得，这个，我的手肘感觉怪怪的。我以为只是因为我在某个时刻像抓了康纳30次。我想，哦，他只是把这只胳膊压在我身上，我抓得太紧了，我以为，只是伤了我的肘部。
So I woke up in the middle of the night and I couldn't touch my elbow to the bed sheet. Jay, you're so lucky you didn't get hurt. I mean you so easily could have just like I know it's so fucking. It could pop out you know. Yeah I mean Sean you said one time it worked right didn't you say that you you you sprained your ankle when you'd come out for curtain call on Will and Grace? By the way sprained ankle is a real pain in the ass. It is. It's the worst. You tripped on Shimada's camera as you were coming out. Wait, Jake, you don't have to take those roles.
所以我半夜醒来，我的手肘都不能碰到床单。杰伊，你太幸运了，没有受伤。我的意思是，你太容易就像我知道这他妈的。它可能会脱臼，你知道的。对，我的意思是，肖恩，你曾说过有一次管用，不是吗？你不是说过你在《威尔和格蕾丝》谢幕时扭伤了脚踝吗？顺便说一句，扭伤脚踝真是一个大麻烦。确实是。这是最糟糕的。你出来时被岛田的相机绊倒了。等等，杰克，你其实不用接那些角色的。
Yeah, you don't have to take those roles. Why don't you get a nice sitcom or something? That's what I'm saying. Like, what is the draw? Why do you, what is the wish? What's the matter with you? I would love to do a sitcom. No one thinks I'm funny.
对，你其实不用接那些角色的。你为什么不接个情景喜剧什么的？这就是我想说的。就像，吸引力在哪里？你为什么，你的愿望是什么？你有什么毛病？我很想演情景喜剧。没有人觉得我搞笑。
I would love to do a sitcom. Everyone's like, he's so serious. This guy's so serious. He thinks so seriously. He like does all this stuff. Like, you know, I would love to do that. I'm doing this because this is what I got, guys. No other options. Nowhere else to go. No, I just love... I love that, like, I love the idea. Well, you're great at it. Yeah, well, you're so brilliant you could do anything. You could just play anything.
我很想演情景喜剧。每个人都觉得：他太严肃了。这家伙太严肃了。他想得太深了。他就像做了所有这些事，你知道的，我很想演。我做这个是因为这是我仅有的，伙计们。别无选择。无处可去。不，我只是喜欢……我喜欢这个，我喜欢这个想法。好吧，你在这方面很棒。对，好吧，你太聪明了，你可以演任何角色。你什么都能演。
They came to me about Roadhouse, too, by the idea. Well, you're great at it. Yeah, well, you're so brilliant, you could do anything. You could just play anything. They came to me about Roadhouse 2, by the way. Uh-oh. I didn't want to say anything, because we were talking about roles we didn't do. It was different, it was more about eating. I don't know if you were talking about food. I don't even try Roadhouse 2. If I knew that you would have been in that movie,
顺便说一句，他们也找过我演《路边饭店2》。哦噢。我什么也没说，因为我们当时在谈论我们没有接的角色。那部不一样，它更多是关于吃的。我不知道你们是不是在谈论食物。我甚至不会去尝试《路边饭店2》。如果我知道你会演那部电影，
we would have had you in that movie. I was up for Roadkill. But anyway, Jake, this is wonderful that you, we took up way too much of your time. You're so sweet to come by. You're very nice to use this with us. Thank you, buddy took up way too much of your time. You're so sweet to come by. Very nice to use this with us. Thank you, buddy. I'm so excited to be here.
我们就会让你加入那部电影。我原本在争取《公路杀戮》。不过无论如何，杰克，很高兴你能来，我们占用了你太多时间。你太贴心了，能抽空过来。你能和我们一起用这个真是太好了。谢谢你，伙计。占用了你太多时间。你太贴心了，能抽空过来。能和我们一起用这个真是太好了。谢谢你，伙计。我很高兴能来到这里。
I'm like, I like, I am, I am, I have, I love your show. I am such a huge fan. I obviously like adore you all from afar and like close up. I invite you places you don't come. Well, I've literally invited you now. So if you don't come, you know, then you're the, so if you don't come you know then you're the same I'm coming with the e-bike option to touch my heart And Jake you'll come over I'll make ice cream and we'll sing yes by the way can we please do that
我喜欢，我喜欢，我是，我有，我喜欢你们的节目。我是如此巨大的粉丝。我显然从远处以及近距离都爱慕着你们。我邀请你们去一些地方，你们都不来。好吧，我现在真的邀请你了。所以如果你不来，你知道的，那你就是那个，所以如果你不来，你知道的，那你就是那个……我带着电单车选项来触动你的心。杰克，你过来吧，我来做冰淇淋，我们一起唱歌。是的，顺便说一句，我们能那样做吗？
Yeah, I'd love to watch please Sean really I would totally love to do that okay? Jake, thank you. All right, I love you, Jake. Thanks, guys. Love you guys, too. Bye, pal. Bye. Bye. Bye.
对，我很想看，求你了，肖恩，我真的非常想那样做，好吗？杰克，谢谢你。好的，我爱你，杰克。谢谢你们。我也爱你们。再见，老兄。再见。再见。再见。
Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye.
再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。
Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. The person who knows the guest the best usually is not the host. That's right. It's odd how that works. I don't know how it works. Did you know him, Will, before? Not really. We've hung out once or twice just briefly and such a nice guy.
再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。最了解嘉宾的人通常不是主持人。没错。这很奇怪，怎么会这样。我不知道它是怎么运作的。威尔，你以前认识他吗？不太认识。我们曾经一起闲逛过一两次，就短短的一会儿，是个非常不错的人。
But I don't really know him. And I knew, I'm just doing this because I like all the different apps. I knew... It's a computer, Jason, it's not gonna work. Oh really, it's gotta be a phone? Yeah. You're on the phone, Will?
但我其实不认识他。我当时知道，我这么做只是因为我喜欢各种不同的应用程序。我知道……这是一台电脑，杰森，它不会起作用。哦真的吗，必须得是手机？对。你在用手机吗，威尔？
No, I'm on my computer. Wait, what? It doesn't work. You didn't update your computer, obviously. But anyway, so nice. I didn't know, JB, I didn't know that you guys knew each other that way. We hung out for a bit there,
不，我在用电脑。等等，什么？它不起作用。显然你没有更新电脑。不过无论如何，太好了。JB，我不知道你们俩是以那种方式认识的。我们在那里闲逛了一会儿，
we got into sort of that bike riding routine for a while and then he got a job or I got a job How did you two meet? How did you two meet? How did you two meet? How did you two meet? How did you two meet? How did you two meet? How did you two meet? How did you two meet? How did you two meet? How did you two meet? How did you two meet? How did you two meet? How did you two meet?
我们有一段时间养成了那种骑自行车的习惯，然后他找到了一份工作，或者我找到了一份工作。你们俩是怎么认识的？你们俩是怎么认识的？你们俩是怎么认识的？你们俩是怎么认识的？你们俩是怎么认识的？你们俩是怎么认识的？你们俩是怎么认识的？你们俩是怎么认识的？你们俩是怎么认识的？你们俩是怎么认识的？你们俩是怎么认识的？你们俩是怎么认识的？你们俩是怎么认识的？
How did you two meet? How did you two meet? How did you two meet? How did you two meet? How did you two meet? How did you two meet? How did you two meet? How did you two meet?
你们俩是怎么认识的？你们俩是怎么认识的？你们俩是怎么认识的？你们俩是怎么认识的？你们俩是怎么认识的？你们俩是怎么认识的？你们俩是怎么认识的？你们俩是怎么认识的？
你们俩是怎么认识的？你们俩是怎么认识的？你们俩是怎么认识的？你们俩是怎么认识的？你们俩是怎么认识的？你们俩-是怎么认识的？你们俩是怎么认识的？你们俩是怎么认识的？
How did you two meet? How did you two meet? How did you two meet? How did you two meet? How did you two meet? How did you two meet? He looks super young. He looks amazing. Yeah, what do we think he is? I would have a good time hanging out with him. Well, cool it. He's 43, I'd say. Is he? Oh wait, he said that, didn't he? Yeah, I think he said 43, yeah. So he is already that young. Our junior.
你们俩是怎么认识的？你们俩是怎么认识的？你们俩是怎么认识的？你们俩是怎么认识的？你们俩是怎么认识的？你们俩是怎么认识的？他看起来超级年轻。他看起来状态惊艳。对，你觉得他多大？和他一起消磨时光应该会很开心。好吧，冷静点。我猜他43岁。是吗？哦等等，他自己说过，对吧？对，我想他说过43岁，对。所以他已经那么年轻了。比我们小。
I mean, can you believe all he's accomplished in 43 years, it's crazy. Yeah. It's amazing. He's made so many movies. Yeah. Well, when he goes, he just goes like, yeah, when I did Darnie Darko, and you're like,
我的意思是，你能相信他在43岁时取得了这么多成就吗，这太疯狂了。对。太棒了。他拍了那么多电影。对。嗯，当他提起时，他就会说，对，当我拍《死亡幻觉》的时候，然后你会觉得，
oh yeah, Donnie Darko, which is a fucking great movie. Yeah, fantastic. That he just, to be able to throw out, like yeah I remember doing, that's like, oh yeah I remember doing this amazing thing. Or fucking Zodiac, you know? Yeah, Zodiac. And then fucking Nightcrawler's incredible,
哦对，唐尼·达科，那是一部他妈的伟大的电影。对，棒极了。他只是，能够随口说出，对，我记得拍过那个，这就好像，哦，对，我记得拍过这个了不起的东西。或者他妈的《十二宫》，你知道吗？对，《十二宫》。还有他妈的《夜行者》，太不可思议了，
if you haven't seen it. Yeah, what have we done with our lives? We're just sitting here. Fucking rash. Eating cake. I know, and I'm back at home. I think you haven't seen it. Yeah, what have we done with our lives? It's just Rash Okay, I know I'm back at home. I'm gone full circle I'm about to get my mom's about to give me shit about the holes of my jeans or something You know what I mean speaking to go on full circle remember the first number the very beginning of this of this podcast today We were talking about Sean's by
如果你还没看过的话。对，我们对自己的生活做了什么？我们只是坐在这里。他妈的皮疹。吃蛋糕。我知道，我又回到了家里。我想你还没看过。对，我们对自己的生活做了什么？这只是皮疹。好吧，我知道我回到了家里。我又回到了原点，我妈快要对我的牛仔裤上的洞或者别的什么东西大发雷霆了。你知道我的意思吗，说到回到原点，还记得这个播客今天开始时的第一个数字，最开始的时候，
Row with biceps biceps biceps last month. No, they last time. Two in a row with biceps. We did biceps last time. They're not going to order in that row. SmartList is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Bennett Barbico, Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Armjarf. If you like SmartList, you can listen early and ad-free right now by joining Wondry Plus in the Wondry app or on Apple Podcasts. Prime members can listen ad free on Amazon Music. Before you go, tell us about yourself
我们讨论的是肖恩的二头肌……二头肌，二头肌，上个月。不，是上一次。连续两次谈到二头肌。我们上次聊了二头肌。它们不会按那个顺序排列。SmartList 由 Bennett Barbico、Michael Grant Terry 和 Rob Armjarf 100% 有机手工制作。如果你喜欢 SmartList，现在就可以通过 Wondry App 或 Apple Podcasts 加入 Wondry Plus，抢先收听无广告版本。Prime 会员可以在 Amazon Music 上免费收听无广告版。在你离开之前，请告诉我们关于你的信息
by filling out a short survey at Wondry.com slash survey. Hey, listener, it's Sean Hayes. Do you know when Crystal Pepsi was discontinued or what was in Al Capone's vault? If not, then you haven't spent enough time on Wikipedia, but that's okay because you can learn all about it on the new podcast, Wiki-Hole, from all of us here at Smartless Media. Discover the craziest rabbit holes on Wikipedia with host Darcy Carden and her favorite comedian friends
通过在 Wondry.com slash survey 填写一份简短的问卷。嘿，听众朋友们，我是肖恩·海斯。你知道水晶百事可乐是什么时候停产的吗，或者阿尔·卡彭的保险库里有什么？如果没有，那你花在维基百科上的时间还不够，不过没关系，因为你可以从我们 Smartless 传媒的每个人这里，在全新的播客 Wiki-Hole 中了解这一切。与主持人达西·卡登（Darcy Carden）和她最喜欢的喜剧演员朋友一起，探索维基百科中最疯狂的兔子洞，
as they bring the cyber frontier directly to your tympanic membrane. And if you listen to WikiHole, you'll learn that's the sciency term for eardrum. WikiHole is the wild, wild west of Wikipedia. Starting out on one Wikipedia page, they go from link to link to link to link, careening through trivia, oddities, and unexpected connections until everyone wonders, how the hell did we get here? Follow WikiHole on the Wondery app
他们将网络前沿直接带入你的鼓膜。如果你听了 Wiki-Hole，你就会知道那是耳膜的科学术语。Wiki-Hole 是维基百科的狂野西部。从维基百科的一个页面出发，他们从一个链接跳到另一个链接，在琐事、奇闻和意想不到的联系中飞驰，直到每个人都在想：我们到底是怎么走到这一步的？在 Wondry App 上关注 Wiki-Hole，
or wherever you get your podcasts. You can listen to WikiHole ad free by joining Wondery, plus in the Wondery app or on Apple podcasts. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
或者在你获取播客的任何地方。通过在 Wondry App 或 Apple Podcasts 上加入 Wondry Plus，你可以无广告收听 Wiki-Hole。这期节目还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。